.
FROM THE FINANCIAL, THIS IS A
MEDICAL SITUATION, NOT A
FINANCIAL SITUATION.
FINANCIAL, THOUGH, IS MOVING
ALONG VERY NICELY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND UPDATE YOU ON THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AFTER A WEEK
OF EXTRAORDINARY MOBILIZATION IN
WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS.
GOVERNORS, MAYORS, BUSINESSES,
CHARITIES AN CITIZENS ALL
WORKING WITH URGENCY AND SPEED
TOWARD ONE COMMON GOAL, WHICH IS
SAVING AMERICAN LIVES.
WE ARE IN COMMUNICATION WITH
FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
IT'S NOW AT 148 FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
YOU TALK ABOUT A SPREAD, YOU
TALK ABOUT A VIOLENT SPREAD.
148 COUNTRIES, NOT EVEN
BELIEVABLE.
THERE'S BEEN A WEEK OF NATIONAL
ACTION AND OF GREAT NATIONAL
SOLIDARITY.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING ALONG.
WE ARE GETTING ALONG.
WE HAVE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS AND
LIBERALS AND CONSERVATIVES AND
ACTUALLY IT'S A VERY NICE THING
TO SEE.
WE ARE ALL ONE BEAUTIFUL BIG
AMERICAN FAMILY AND THAT'S
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW.
LAST NIGHT I APPROVED MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATION FOR THE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
I WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
GOVERNOR CUOMO AND IT'S THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY THAT A PRESIDENT USED
THE STAFFORD ACT TO DECLARE
MAJOR RESPONSE, NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE.
CONSIDERING OTHER AREAS WHERE WE
MAY OR MAY NOT BE DOING IT YET
AND WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
GAVIN NEWSOM, GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, AND OTHERS.
WE MAY BE DOING THE SAME THING
DEPENDING ON THEIR NEEDS AND
DEPENDING ON WHAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR.
IT'S BEEN UNPRECEDENTED ACTION
IN NEW YORK AND WE'VE HAD A
TREMENDOUS FEDERAL RESPONSE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
I WANT TO THANK THE PEOPLE AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, WE ARE WORKING
HARD, EVERYBODY IS WORKING HARD
AND THE PEOPLE STANDING ALONG
SIDE OF ME ARE WORKING VERY
HARD.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU.
WE'VE ALSO REACHED AGREEMENTS
WITH CANADA AND MÉXICO ON NEW
TRAVEL RULES ON NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN BORDERS TO HALT THE
ENTRY OF THE CHINESE VIRUS WHILE
CONTINUING TRADE AND COMMERCE
AND WE'VE HAD VERY GOOD TALKS.
PRIME MINISTER TRUDEAU AND TODAY
THIS MORNING WITH PRESIDENT
LOPEZ OBRADOR.
WE TALKED ABOUT JOINT MEASURES
THAT WE ARE TAKING TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS IN OUR
COUNTRIES AND TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL.
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING WITH PRESIDENT OF MÉXICO
AND OUR CLOSE COOPERATION WITH
MÉXICO AND CANADA WILL KEEP OUR
PEOPLE HEALTHY AND KEEP THEIR
PEOPLE HEALTHY, KEEP EVERYBODY
SAFE.
YESTERDAY I HAD A CALL WITH
12,000 SMALL BUSINESSES
REPRESENTATIVES OF THESE
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S THE ENGINE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT.
YOU READ ALL ABOUT THE BIG ONES
BUT THE SMALL BUSINESS, WHEN YOU
ADD THEM TOGETHER, IT'S REALLY
THE ENGINE, ECONOMIC ENGINE OF
THE COUNTRY AND I ASSURED THEM
THAT MY ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
EVERYTHING WITH CONSIDERABLE
POWER FRANKLY TO SUPPORT THEM
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
NOBODY HAS EVER DONE WHAT WE
HAVE DONE.
LIKE WISE I HAD CALLS DURING
WEEK WITH ALL SORTS OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND SYSTEMS LIKE
THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
WE SPOKE TO MANY OF THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY,
NURSES AND DOCTORS REPRESENTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF NURSES
AND DOCTORS.
AIRLINES AND CRUISE SHIP
COMPANIES.
THE BUSINESS ROUND TABLE WHICH
WAS FULLY ATTENDED AND IT'S ALL
ABOUT OF THE TOP CEO'S OF -- OF
OUR COUNTRY AND BEYOND FRANKLY
THE BUSINESSMEN OF THE
WORLD-STYLE BUSINESSMEN, THE
BUSINESSMEN THAT CONTROL THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
MANY OF THEM HAVE TAKEN HITS AND
MANY GOING FORWARD THAT
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN GREAT, SOME
BADLY AFFECTED, SOME HAVEN'T
BEEN AFFECTED AT ALL AND FRANKLY
SOME ARE DOING VERY WELL.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO VERY WELL.
WAL-MART IS AN EXAMPLE, HAS BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL TO US.
DOUG MCMILAN OUT OF WAL-MART
REALLY HELPFUL TO US AND I
ASSUME THEY ARE DOING PRETTY
WELL BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE BUYING
MORE THAN EVEN A CLIP AT
CHRISTMAS BY SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBERS.
PRETTY AMAZING.
THEY ARE I THINK INCREDIBLE BY.
THEY PUT ON TREMENDOUS EXTRA
STAFF.
YOU DON'T HAVE EMPTY SHELVES.
A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE VERY
GOOD.
RESTAURANTS, GROCERY STORES, ALL
RETAILERS, LITERALLY ALL OF THEM
IN GROUPS AND WE SPOKE WITH THE
G7 LEADERS AT LENGTH AS YOU
KNOW, YOU PROBABLY KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
SPOKE TO MANY OF THE GOVERNORS,
SPOKE TO ALMOST ALL OF THE
GOVERNORS IN CONFERENCE CALLS
AND MANY GOVERNORS INDIVIDUALLY
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY THE
RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY, THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND MYSELF, WITH THE RELIGIOUS
LEADERS OF OUR COUNTRY, MANY OF
THE RELIGIOUS LEADERS AND WE'VE
HAD THE NUMBER OF THEM OVER THE
COURSE OF WEEKS ACTUALLY AND
YESTERDAY WE HAD A VERY, VERY
SIGNIFICANT CALL WITH THE
RELIGIOUS LEADERS OF OUR
COUNTRY.
I SIGNED LEGISLATION PROVIDING
AMERICAN WORKERS WITH PAID SICK
LEAVE AND PAID FAMILY MEDICAL
LEAVE AT NO COST TO EMPLOYERS
AND FREE TESTING FOR THOSE WHO
NEED IT.
THE TESTING IS GOING VERY WELL
AND THE ADMIRABLE WILL SPEAK TO
THAT ALONG WITH TONY.
WE ARE WORKING TO PASS
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE MASSIVE RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND AFFECTED
INDUSTRIES AND PAYMENTS TO
WORKERS AND HARD-WORKING
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANYTHING LIKE
WE ARE DOING ON THE HILL RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE NEGOTIATING, MITCH
MCCONNELL, CHUCK SCHUMER,
THEY'RE ALL UP THERE, KEVIN
MCCARTHY, AND NANCY PELOSI,
THEY'RE ALL NEGOTIATING AND
EVERYBODY IS WORKING HARD AND
THEY WANT TO GET TO A SOLUTION
THAT'S THE RIGHT SOLUTION.
I THINK WE ARE GETTING VERY
CLOSE.
WE'VE ALSO ANNOUNCED THAT WE'VE
MOVED TAX DAY FROM APRIL 15TH TO
JULY 15TH WHICH IS A BIG DEAL
GIVING BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS EXTRA TIME TO FILE
AND PAY WITHOUT INTEREST OR
PENALTIES.
SO WE MOVED THE DATE WAY BACK
AND SO IT'LL BE JULY 15TH
INSTEAD OF YOUR TRADITIONAL
APRIL 15TH AND VERY IMPORTANTLY,
YOU WILL HAVE A LOT OF TIME, BUT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
INTEREST PENALTIES OR ANY KIND
OF PENALTIES BY FILING AT THE
LATER DATE.
HUD ANNOUNCED THAT FORECLOSURES
AND EVICTIONS ARE SUSPENDED FOR
SINGLE-FAMILY HOMEOWNERS WITH
FHA MORTGAGES FOR THE NEXT 60
DAYS AND OUR GREAT HEAD OF HUD
WHO IS WITH US TODAY, BEN
CARSON, WILL SAY A FEW WORDS IN
A MOMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
NOT ENFORCE STANDARDIZED TESTING
WHICH IS ANOTHER BIG DEAL,
REQUIREMENTS FOR STUDENTS IN
ELEMENTARY THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
FOR THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR.
NOT FAIR TO DO THAT.
SO WE ARE WAIVING THAT.
I WOULD IMAGINE IT'S PROBABLY
THE FIRST TIME EVER THAT'S BEEN
WAIVED, BUT I THINK IT'S ONLY
FAIR TO THE STUDENTS AND TO THE
PARENTS OF THE STUDENTS.
IT IS ALSO WAIVING INTEREST AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING RIGHT NOW ON
FEDERALLY HELD STUDENT LOANS AND
DIRECTED THAT BORROWERS BE
ALLOWED TO SUSPEND STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS WITHOUT PENALTY FOR AT
LEAST 60 DAYS AND WE WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT STUDENT LOANS,
HELP STUDENTS UNDER GREAT BURDEN
RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THAT
FURTHER BUT WE ARE -- WE ARE
WAIVING DURING THE 60-DAY PERIOD
VARIOUS ELEMENTS, VERY IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS ON STUDENT LOANS.
BIG SUBJECT.
I SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
INVOKING THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT AS YOU ALL KNOW GIVING US
POWERFUL NEW AUTHORITIES TO HELP
STATES, CITIES AND HOSPITALS
PROCURE NEEDED SUPPLIES.
THERE'S BEEN A CLEAR CUT TO
ACTION TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
THE CALL IS MADE RIGHT HERE.
IT'S BEEN REALLY PRETTY AMAZING
WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THEY ARE REALLY IN SIXTH YEAR, I
THINK, WHICH HAS RESPONDED AND
SUPPLIED MUCH NEEDED MASKS,
SWABS, VENTILATORS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THERE'S A MOVE ON THAT THAT'S
INCREDIBLE RIGHT NOW, AND BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE,HANES, RETRO FITTING
MANUFACTURING CAPABILITIES IN
LARGE SECTIONS OF THE PLANTS TO
PRODUCE MASKS AND THEIR IN THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
IN MY DIRECTION THE FDA HAS
TAKEN RAPID STEPS TO MAKE THE
ITEMS AVAILABLE FOR MEDICAL USE
RIGHT NOW.
MOST EXCITINGLY TO ME IS WHAT
THE FDA HAS DONE IN ORDER TO GET
POSSIBLY A VERY SUCCESSFUL
NUMBER, NOT JUST ONE OR TWO,
NUMBER OF THERAPEUTICS,
MEDICINES THAT CAN HELP, HELP
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY SICK,
HELP PEOPLE NOT GET SICK AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
VACCINE AND TONY WILL DISCUSS
THAT LITTLE BIT LATER BUT THE
VACCINE IS MOVING ALONG, BUT
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT FOR
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS WHAT WE
REALLY -- IT'S INCREDIBLE.
WHAT THE FDA HAS DONE AND
DR. STEVEN HANH WHO IS
RESPECTED, FANTASTIC, HE'S ONLY
BEEN HERE FOR A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AND HE'S GOTTEN THROWN INTO THE
SWIM OF IT AND HE'LL REALLY
STANDING UP, BUT THE FDA HAS
MOVED MOUNTAINS.
I SAID THIS MORNING THEY MOVED
MOUNTAINS TO GET APPROVALS ON
THINGS THAT MAYBE WORK.
WE WILL FIND OUT SOON AND
EXAMPLE OF PURE NORA CARD, THIS
IS REALLY AN EXAMPLE WHERE WE
ARE REPURPOSING ALCOHOL.
THEY WENT OUT AND REPURPOSING
ALCOHOL CAPABILITIES IN
ARKANSAS, KENTUCKY, TEXAS AND
WEST VIRGINIA TO MAKE HAND
SANITIZER.
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THEY HAVE BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
THEIR FIRST DELIVERY WILL BE ON
TUESDAY.
IT'S GOING TO VARIOUS STATES.
THEY WILL START IN NEW YORK AND
WORK THEIR WAY AROUND.
THEY ARE MAKING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF HAND SANITIZER AT HIGH
LEVEL TOO, BY THE WAY.
WE'VE ACTIVATED THE NATIONAL
RESPONSE COORDINATION CENTER TO
LEVEL 1, THAT'S YOUR HIGHEST
LEVEL.
THE NERVE CENTER OF ALL OF OUR
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE TO CRISIS
AND COORDINATING CLOSELY WITH
OUR NATION'S GOVERNORS, OUR
NATION'S GOVERNORS.
MANY OF YOU WERE AT THE CALLS
WITH THE GOVERNORS AND I THINK
YOU'VE SEEN THE RELATIONSHIP.
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS CALLS BUT THE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE PRETTY
AMAZING.
THEY ARE LOVING WHAT WE ARE
DOING AND THE COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE GOVERNORS, STATES AND
EVEN LOCAL HAS BEEN PRETTY
INCREDIBLE.
FEMA ADMINISTRATIVE PETE GAINER,
WHO IS WITH US, WILL PROVIDE
UPDATE OF THE CENTER'S
OPERATIONS AND FEMA HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE.
WE'VE GOT THEM INVOLVED LAST
WEEK.
VERY MUCH INVOLVED.
THEY ARE INVOLVED NATIONWIDE.
WE EXPANDED TELEHEALTH SO
AMERICANS CAN SEE A DOCTOR
WITHOUT LEAVING HOME.
SOMETHING WHICH MORE PEOPLE ARE
USING AND NOW THEY ARE REALLY
USING IT AND THE ONES THAT ARE
USING IT ARE LOVING IT AND I
THINK WE WILL CHANGE THE WAY OUR
COUNTRY FUNCTIONS MEDICALLY AND
PROBABLY IN OTHER WAYS BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
THIS WILL REDUCE THE CHANCE OF
INFECTION AND PRESERVE HOSPITAL
CAPACITY, SO SOLVES A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
EVERY AMERICAN HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY IN DEFENDING OUR NATION
FROM THIS INVISIBLE, HORRIBLE
ENEMY.
IT REALLY IS.
IT'S AN INVISIBLE ENEMY AND WE
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL, VERY
SUCCESSFUL, HOPEFULLY VERY MUCH
SOONER THAN PEOPLE THINK.
WE SAY STAY AT HOME AND SAVE
LIVES.
THERE'S A TIME OF SHARED
NATIONAL SACRIFICE BUT ALSO A
TIME TO TREASURE OUR LOVED ONES
AND TAKE STOCK OF WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT, FAITH, FAMILIES, OUR
NEIGHBORS AND OUR GREAT COUNTRY
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE OF OUR
COUNTRY, THE CITIZENS OF OUR
COUNTRY THAT -- WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND THE WAY YOU'RE RESPONDING IS
JUST HAS JUST BEEN VERY SPECIAL,
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL NEVER
FORGET, THAT THE HISTORY BOOKS
WILL NEVER FORGET, AND WE WILL
HAVE A GREAT VICTORY.
WE WILL BE CELEBRATING A VICTORY
IN NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY AND I
WANT TO INTRODUCE OUR VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WHO HAS LED
THE TASK FORCE AND I WILL TELL
YOU THIS, HE HAS NOT SLEPT MUCH,
MAYBE A TINNY BIT, MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT BUT NOT MUCH, AND
HE'S DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB,
MIKE, THANK YOU, PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL, AND THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE MET TODAY.
WE BRIEFED THE PRESIDENT ON OUR
LATEST RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE CONTINUE AT THE PRESIDENT'S
DIRECTION AND TO LEAD NOT A HOLD
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH BUT
AMERICA APPROACH.
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT
DESCRIBING ONE INSPIRING STORY
AFTER ANOTHER THE WAY AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE RESPONDING AND
AMERICAN BUSINESSES ARE
RESPONDING, RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
COMING TOGETHER.
THEY ARE RESPONDING WITH EXPERT
WITNESS, COMPASSION AND
GENEROSITY.
PEOPLE ARE HEEDING THE ADVICE OF
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND
TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE PUTTING INTO PRACTICE 15
DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
WE ARE -- WE ARE OFFICIALLY,
MR. PRESIDENT, 6 DAYS INTO OUR
15 DAYS AND AS WE LOOK ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WHILE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE DECISIONS
THAT GOVERNORS AND STATES WHERE
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT OUTBREAK
HAVE TAKEN, WE ENCOURAGE EVERY
AMERICAN TO LISTEN TO THOSE
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
FOR EVERY AMERICAN, THIS IS WHAT
YOU CAN DO TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
OVER THE NEXT WEEK AND FEW DAYS
TO PROTECT YOUR HEALTH, PROTECT
YOUR FAMILY'S HEALTH BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY SLOW THE SPREAD AND
POTENTIAL FOR CORONAVIRUS TO
IMPACT THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID, WE'VE
BEEN -- WE'VE ALMOST BEEN
OVERWHELMED AT THE OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT FROM AMERICAN
BUSINESSES, THE PRESIDENT SPOKE
YESTERDAY TO THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES.
WE SPOKE TO MANUFACTURERS
YESTERDAY AND, IN FACT, AS THE
PRESIDENT INDICATED THE FDA IN
-- IN RECORD TIME JUST TO PROVE
ONE MANUFACTURER THAT WILL BE
PRODUCING MILLIONS OF SURGICAL
MASKS IN A MATTER OF WEEKS FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PASTORS WE SPOKE TO, WE WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE RELIGIOUS
LEADERS FROM EVERY COMMUNITY OF
FAITH IN THE COUNTRY MAKING THE
HARD CHOICE TO SUSPEND SERVICES,
TO HAVE ONLINE SERVICES EVEN
WHILE MIN RISK ARE -- MINISTRIES
SUPPORTING FOOD BANKS AND
PRAYERS COMING UP FROM
COMMUNITIES OF FAITH AROUND THE
COUNTRY IS MAKING THE DIFFERENCE
THAT IT ALWAYS HAS AND THE LIFE
OF THIS NATION.
ONE THING THE PRESIDENT AND I
PROMISED WAS TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT ON THE WEEKENDS THAT YOU'RE
NOT IN THE FUSE, IT'S STILL A
GOOD -- IT'S STILL A GOOD IDEA
THAT IF YOU CAN TO GO AHEAD AND
MAKE THAT DONATION.
ALL THE MINISTRIES ARE
CONTINUING TO PLAY A VITAL ROLE
IN THE COMMUNITIES AND WE HOPE
TO CONTINUE YOUR SUPPORT.
WE ARE LISTENING TO STATE AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND PUTTING
INTO PRACTICE ALL OF -- ALL OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
PRESIDENT'S CORONAVIRUS
GUIDELINES AND AS YOU WILL HEAR
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS FROM
ADMIRAL TESTING IS EXPANDING
RAPIDLY ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
STATE-RUN DRIVE-THRUS ARE
EXPANDING ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
AS YOU WILL HEAR DETAIL, MORE
THAN 195,000 AMERICANS AND MORE
WHO HAVE BEEN SYMPTOMATIC HAVE
BEEN TESTED.
THAT NUMBER DOES NOT INCLUDE
COUNTY HOSPITALS OR -- OR
HEALTHCARE LABS AROUND THE
NATION.
SOME 15,000 IN NUMBER.
AND AMONG THE NUMBER OF THE MORE
THAN 195,000 THAT HAVE BEEN
FESTED, IT'S -- TESTED IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT ONLY
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE CONTINUE TO URGE STATE AND
LOCAL HEALTH AUTHORITIES TO
CONTACT FEMA FOR ALL THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS AND INNOVATIONS IN
TESTING, BUT WE WANT TO REMIND
AMERICANS AS DR. FAUCI WILL
EMPHASIZE IN A MOMENT, IF YOU
DON'T HAVE SYMPTOMS, DON'T DO A
TEST.
IT IS ANOTHER WAY THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PRESERVING THE
RESOURCES THAT OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS NEED TO MINISTER AND TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO ARE DEALING
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AND OTHER
ILLNESSES.
IN A MOMENT, PETE GAINER WILL
DETAIL EFFORTS AT FEMA SINCE
PRESIDENT'S NATIONAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
WE HAVE FEMA IN THE LEAD, STOOD
UP COORDINATION CENTER AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID AND WORKING
CLOSELY, LITERALLY HOUR BY HOUR
THROUGH FEMA PROCESSING REQUESTS
FROM STATES MOST IMPACTED LIKE
NEW YORK, WASHINGTON STATE AND
CALIFORNIA AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THOSE
STATES THROUGH THE VERY
TRADITIONAL MEANS OF FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AT FEMA.
SECRETARY CARSON WILL DESCRIBE
DECISIVE ACTIONS THE PRESIDENT
ALLUDED TO, TO BRING FORECLOSURE
RELIEF TO AMERICANS.
AND ON THE SUBJECTS OF SUPPLIES,
IN A MOMENT, YOU WILL HEAR OF
NOT ONLY THE PROGRESS THAT WE
ARE MAKING ON TESTING BUT ON
MONDAY WE WILL BE DETAILING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE PROGRESS
THAT WE ARE MAKING ON THE
PRESIDENT'S STRATEGY OF
PROCURING MORE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES, ALLOCATING THEM
THROUGH THE SYSTEM OF FEMA AND
CONTINUING TO URGE CONSERVATION
BY AMERICANS.
IN FACT, I'M PLEASED TO REPORT
TO THE PRESIDENT TODAY THAT HHS
PLACED AN ORDER FOR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF N95 MASKS THAT WILL
BE BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT, WE
DO RENEW OUR CALL TO AMERICANS
TO POSTPONE ELECTIVE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES INCLUDING DENTAL
SERVICES AND, REMEMBER, THIS IS
ANOTHER WAY THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT MEDICAL SUPPLIES
ARE AVAILABLE BECAUSE BY
POSTPONING ELECTED MEDICAL
PROCEDURES YOU'RE FREEING UP
MEDICAL SUPPLIES FOR THOSE
DEALING WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
AS THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED, OUR
TEAM IS ON CAPITOL HILL AS WE
SPEAK WORKING WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS IN BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES.
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS BY ALL
ACCOUNTS ON A BIPARTISAN BILL.
THEY WORKED LATE INTO THE NIGHT
LAST NIGHT, STARTED EARLY THIS
MORNING AND WE ARE WORKING TO
PASS THE LEGISLATION ON MONDAY
IN BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
NOW ON A PERSONAL NOTE MANY OF
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE OF
THAT A MEMBER OF MY STAFF HAS
TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE LEARNED OF THAT LATE
YESTERDAY.
I'M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT HE'S
DOING WELL.
HE HAD MILD COLD-LIKE SYMPTOMS
FOR ABOUT A DAY AND A HALF, HAS
NOT BEEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE
SINCE MONDAY.
NEITHER THE PRESIDENT NOR I HAD
DIRECT CONTACT WITH THAT STAFF
PERSON.
WE WORKED IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN AND THE
CDC.
WE'VE DONE ALL CONTACT TRACING
AND THE WHITE HOUSE DOCTORS
INDICATED THAT HE HAS NO REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT I WAS EXPOSED
AND NO NEED TO BE TESTED GIVEN
THE UNIQUE POSITION I HAVE AS
VICE PRESIDENT AND AS THE LEADER
OF THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
BOTH I AND MY WIFE WILL BE
TESTED LATER THIS AFTERNOON.
LET ME SAY AGAIN HOW GRATEFUL
THE PRESIDENT AND I ARE THAT
EVERY AMERICAN HAS ACTED ON THE
PRESIDENT'S CORONAVIRUS
GUIDELINES.
WE ARE 6 DAYS INTO 15 DAYS THAT
HAS DR. FAUCI MAY WELL REFLECT
IN A MOMENT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US HERE ON THE FOOTHOLDS OF
THIS EPIDEMIC CURVE IN OUR
COUNTRY, LITERALLY LOWER THE
IMPACT IN OUR NATION AND SAVE
LIVES.
EVERY AMERICAN CAN DO THEIR PART
TO SLOW THE SPREAD AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU EACH TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAYS OFTEN,
REMEMBER WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND ALSO REMEMBER THAT
-- THAT FOR MOST AMERICANS THE
RISK OF SERIOUS ILLNESS FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS REMAINS LOW.
THE REASON WE WANT TO PUT INTO
PRACTICE THE PRESIDENT'S
CORONAVIRUS GUIDELINE IS BECAUSE
NO AMERICA WOULD WANT TO
INADVERTENTLY EXPOSE SOMEONE WHO
IS VULNERABLE, A SENIOR WITH A
SERIOUS UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITION TO THE CORONAVIRUS
WITH THE POTENTIAL THREAT.
I DID HEAR ONE STORY THIS
MORNING, MR. PRESIDENT, ABOUT A
SENIOR NAMED GENEVA WOOD, SHE'S
AT THE LIFE CARE CENTER IN
KIRKLAND, WASHINGTON, SHE'S NOT
ONLY A GRANDMOTHER BUT A GREAT,
GREAT GRANDMOTHER.
90 YEAR'S OLD YOUNG AND SHE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS ON MARCH SIXTH.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS SHE'S DOING
WELL.
SHE WANTED AMERICA TO KNOW THAT
THERE IS HOPE AND HER STRENGTH
AND HER ENTHUSIASM IS TRULY AN
INSPIRATION TO THE NATION.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID MANY
TIMES, WE ARE GOING TO GET
THROUGH THIS AND COME OUT
STRONGER THAN EVER BEFORE AND WE
WILL GET THROUGH THIS AS
AMERICANS TOGETHER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MIKE.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
VICE PRESIDENT.
AS I TOLD YOU EARLIER LAST WEEK,
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS AND/OR
EFFECTIVELY TRANSITIONING TO
LARGE-SCALE TESTING BY
LEVERAGING ALL THE COMPONENTS OF
THE AMERICAN HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
WHEN WE STARTED IT WAS CDC ONLY
AND IT WAS THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORIES.
NOW WE ARE TRANSITIONING INTO
THE MAINSTREAM OF AMERICAN
TESTING WITH MANY OF THE
COMPANIES THAT THE PRESIDENT
INVITED IN THE ROSE GARDEN JUST
A WEEK AGO.
SO CURRENTLY 91 PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORIES, STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORIES ARE UP AND
RUNNING IN 50 STATES, DISTRICT
OF COLOMBIA, GUAM AND PUERTO
RICO.
THIS IS OUR ROLE, AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS, THIS ONLY
ACCOUNTS FOR CDC STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORIES AND
LABORATORIES THAT ARE MEMBERS OF
THE AMERICAN CLINICAL
LABORATORIES ASSOCIATION.
THESE ARE THE MAIN REFERENCE
LABORATORIES, LAB CORP., QUEST,
MAYO, BIOREFERENCE LABS AND
SONIC HEALTHCARE, IT DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR THE WELL OVER
10,000, 15,000 HOSPITAL BASE
LABS, MANY OF WHICH ARE DOING
TESTING FOR WHOM WE WILL GET
DATA THIS WEEK TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERALL ROLLOFF.
AS YOU CAN SEE 195,000 PEOPLE IN
AMERICA HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
TESTING.
THAT MEANS TEST PLUS RESULTS.
THIS DOES NOT COUNT THE PEOPLE
WHOSE TEST ARE IN PROCESS AND AS
YOU SEE THIS CURVE THAT'S GOING,
IT WILL CONTINUE TO RISE
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE NEXT
PERIOD OF TIME.
SO, AGAIN, THIS IS UTILIZING ALL
OF THE COMPONENTS OF THE GREAT
AMERICAN HEALTHCARE SYSTEM, THE
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORIES, THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM WHICH IS NOT REPRESENTED
HERE AND THE MAIN REFERENCE
LABORATORIES.
NOW, I DO WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT ALTHOUGH TESTING IS
BECOMING MORE AVAILABLE AND
DR. FAUCI WILL DEFINITELY
EMPHASIZE THIS MORE, THERE ARE
PRIORITIES FOR TESTING AND
CLEARLY EVERYONE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE HOSPITALIZED IN ICU ARE IN
PRIORITY FOR TESTING,
SYMPTOMATIC HEALTHCARE WORKERS,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
HEALTHCARE IS PRESERVED AND THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO SPREAD TO THOSE
WHO ARE SERIOUSLY ILL.
SYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE IN LONG-TERM
CARE FACILITIES AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT HIGHLIGHTED AND WE
SAID MANY TIMES, ELDERLY IN OUR
SOCIETY HAVE A MUCH HIGHER
MORTALITY RATE, MUCH HIGHER
SERIOUS COMPLICATION RATE.
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS OVER 65,
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS LIKE
CHRONIC HEART DISEASE OR LIVER
DISEASE OR OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES, PATIENTS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INVESTIGATIONS AND LOCAL
PRIORITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
PARTICULARLY HEALTHCARE WORKERS
FOR TESTING, AND DR. FAUCI WILL
EMPHASIZE THIS ABOUT THE TYPES
OF PEOPLE WHO DO NOT NEED TO BE
TESTING.
FINALLY, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY-BASE TESTING
SITES.
I KNOW THERE ARE POPULAR NOW
BECAUSE THERE'S NOW AN ACRONYM
WHICH I'M SURE THE VICE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T APPRECIATE.
CBTS, CBT SITES, WE TALKED ABOUT
THESE EARLIER IN THE WEEK, I
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT
THESE ARE STATE MANAGED AND
LOCALLY EXECUTED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THERE
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT, NO-HOW,
BLUEPRINTS ON HOW TO DO THIS BUT
THESE ARE REALLY SPRINGING UP AT
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF SITES ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY ADAPTED TO THE
LOCAL NEEDS.
SOME ARE DRIVE-THRU, SOME ARE
WALK-UP, SOME ARE GEARED TO
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS.
AGAIN, WHAT WE SEE IN THE
UPCOMING WEEK IS THIS CURVE WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE AS TESTING
BECOMES MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE AS
THE GREAT AMERICAN HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF TESTS AND
GROUP OF THOSE TESTS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT,
WHAT I WILL DO OVER THE NEXT
MINUTE OR SO CONNECT SOME OF THE
DOTS, THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY.
FIRST THE STATUS OF THE DYNAMICS
OF THE OUTBREAK.
I MEAN, YOU ALL KNOW THE
NUMBERS.
YOU'VE SEEN THEM.
WE HAVE WIDESPREAD INFECTION BUT
TO VARYING DEGREES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
MITIGATION ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
PUT FORTH AND HAVE EMPHASIZED,
JUST AS I MENTIONED THE OTHER
DAY, THERE ARE TWO DYNAMIC
FORCES GOING ON AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU HAVE HAVING THE THE NATURAL
COURSE OF AN OUTBREAK TRYING TO
PEAK AT A HIGH LEVEL AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES WHICH ARE AIMED AT
DAMPENING THAT.
YOU MENTIONED THAT MULTIPLE
TIMES.
WE OFTEN GET ASKED HOW DO YOU
KNOW YOU'RE HAVING AN EFFECT
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO THINGS
GOING ON AT THE SAME TIME THEY
MAY BE CONFOUNDING.
WELL, I CAN TELL YOU FOR SURE
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT
AND EXPERIENCE FROM OTHER
OUTBREAKS, WE KNOW CLEARLY
HAVING AN EFFECT BUT WE CAN'T
QUANTITATE IT FOR YOU ACCURATELY
NOW BECAUSE LOOKING FORWARD,
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT THE IMPACT TO
HAVE RATE OF THE INCLINES WILL
BE.
THAT'S WHY WE WILL COME BACK
EVERY DAY AND KEEP YOU UP TO
DATE ABOUT THAT.
GETTING WITH REGARD TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE OF THE RESPONSE
, EVERYONE THAT'S RIGHT
HERE, I WILL OPEN UP THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S BOOK WITH HIS
PERMISSION, THIS IS BASELINE FOR
EVERYONE, IN OTHER WORDS,
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, BUT THEN
THEY'LL BE AREAS, AND YOU HEARD
THEM, WASHINGTON STATE,
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK CITY, IN
WHICH THE DYNAMICS OF THE
OUTBREAK ARE CLEARLY DIFFERENT
AND MUCH MORE ROBUST, IF YOU
WANT TO USE THAT WORD.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
SEEN THE MITIGATION RATCHET IT
UP IN THAT REGARD AND AGAIN,
HOPEFULLY, AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT IT WILL HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE IMPACT ON THAT.
NEXT GETTING TO TESTING, YOU SAW
THE NUMBERS WITH TESTING.
REMEMBER THERE WAS ALWAYS AN
ISSUE WITH TESTING.
I THINK WE ARE GETTING TO THE
SOLUTION THAT EVERYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY IS LOOKING FOR, BUT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE ONE THING THAT
ADMIRAL GEOIR MENTIONED, THAT
NOT EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE
UNITED STATES NEEDS TO GET
TESTED.
HE GAVE YOU THE PRIORITIES, I
DON'T WANT TO REPEAT THEM, BUT
LET ME TELL YOU ONE OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T NEED TO
GET TESTED THAT FLOOD THE DESIRE
TO GET TESTED.
HOPEFULLY CHANGE IT AND MAKE IT
MUCH LESS RELIABLE ON PPE'S.
WHEN YOU GO IN AND GET TESTED
YOU ARE CONSUMING PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, MASKS AND
GOWNS.
THOSE ARE HIGH PRIORITY FOR
WORKERS WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CORONAVIRUS
DISEASE.
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE WE WILL HAVE
DISPARITIES AND AVAILABILITIES
OF PPE'SOW AND WE ARE WORKING
HARD TO CORRECT THAT, BUT
CURRENTLY TODAY, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE WITH
CORONAVIRUS DISEASE DO NOT
ENDANGER THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
FINALLY, ONE LAST THING, WE JUST
MENTIONED THE SURGEON GENERAL
HAS BEEN PUSHING THIS, PLEASE
PUT OFF, CANCEL ELECTIVE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO EVER NOT DO
THEM BUT FOR THE TIME BEING
DON'T DO THEM BECAUSE THEY NOT
ONLY CONSUME PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, THEY MAY ALSO CONSUME
SOME OF THE THINGS LIKE
VENTILATORS THAT YOU MIGHT NEED.
LET'S PULL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
WE WILL GET THROUGH THIS, I
PROMISE YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
FEMA IS NOW LEADING THE FEDERAL
OPERATION, ALL THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE FOR ALL OPERATIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WHO
OVERSEES NATION RESPONSE.
HHS WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THEIR EXPERTS, MATTER OF
EXPERTISE ON HEALTH AND PURSUANT
TO THE NATIONWIDE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION FEMA IN COORDINATION
WITH HHS IS ASSISTING STATE,
LOCAL, TRIBAL TERRITORIAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OTHER ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY
EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE MEASURES ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
AS OF YESTERDAY, 50 STATES, THE
DISTRICT OF COLOMBIA, 5
TERRITORIES AND ONE TRIBE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH FEMA UNDER
THE NATIONWIDE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION FOR COVID-19.
IN JUST 24 HOURS, WE'VE
OBLIGATED $100 MILLION TO
STATES, TERRITORIES AND TRIBES.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SUPPLIES, IT
IS UPMOST IMPORTANT THAT REQUEST
ESPECIALLY FOR CRITICAL SUPPLIES
GET ROUTED THROUGH PROPER
CHANNELS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
WE ASKED WHEN TO FOLLOW NORMAL
PROCEDURES, NORMAL PROCEDURES
FEMA USES IN NATURAL DISASTER.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENT PROCEDURE
FOR COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
BUT, REMEMBER, YOU CAN STILL
ORDER SUPPLIES FROM YOUR REGULAR
VENDERS AND BUY ON OPEN MARKET,
BUY IT WHERE YOU CAN FIND IT.
WE WILL REIMBURSE YOU.
IF YOU BUY MEDICAL SUPPLIES FROM
FOREIGN SOURCES IT IS
REIMBURSABLE.
IF YOU CAN'T BUY IT ON THE OPEN
MARKET, MAKE A REQUEST THROUGH
THE FEMA SYSTEM, REQUEST FOR
ASSISTANCE AT THE LOCAL AND
COUNTY LEVELS SHOULD FIRST GO TO
STATES, FROM STATES TO REGIONAL
FEMA OFFICE AND THEN FROM THOSE
OFFICES RIGHT HERE IN DC WHERE
THE NATIONAL RESPONSE
COORDINATION CENTER IS OPEN AND
RUNNING.
WE ARE GETTING REQUESTS FOR
MASKS, PPE'S, SWAB SETS, TEST
SITE SUPPORTS, VENTILATORS,
HOSPITAL CAPACITY ASSESSMENTS
AND MANY MORE.
WE ARE IN LOCK STEP WITH HHS TO
ANSWER THESE REQUESTS, BUT WE
WILL DO WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO
GET STATES, TRIBES, TERRITORIES
AND OTHERS WHAT THEY NEED.
AND THEN FINALLY, WHAT WE ARE
DOING HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
LIKE MOST SUCCESSFUL WHEN IT IS
LOCALLY EXECUTED, STATE MANAGED
AND FEDERALLY SUPPORTED.
WE CAN'T SAY THAT ENOUGH.
ON THURSDAY OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
INTEGRATED WITH NATIONAL
COORDINATION RESPONSE
COORDINATION CENTER AND
ADDITIONALLY ALL FEMA REGIONS
HAVE BEEN ACTIVATED.
WE WILL COORDINATE WITH STATE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
DETERMINE THE TYPE OF LEVELS
NEEDED TO RESPOND TO DYNAMIC
THREAT.
THANK YOU, SIR.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MR. VICE PRESIDENT FOR YOUR
TIRELESS LEADERSHIP HERE AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE FELLOW
TASK FORCE MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK, VERY
PATRIOTIC WAY TO SERVE FELLOW
AMERICANS.
YOU KNOW, PART OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM IS HAVING A HOME AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY, WELL, WHAT
DOES HOUSING HAVE TO DO WITH
HEALTH, IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH HEALTH, HAVING A SAFE HOME.
THAT'S THE REASON THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS AUTHORIZED THE
IMMEDIATE SUSPENSION OF
FORECLOSURE AND EVICTION
PROCEEDINGS FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS, SINGLE-FAMILY,
MORTGAGES, AS WELL AS REVERSE
MORTGAGES.
AND AS YOU KNOW, IF -- FHFA HAS
DECIDED TO DO THAT FOR 60 DAYS
AND IT'S REALLY ALL ABOUT
HELPING OUR PEOPLE, RECOGNIZING
THAT THEY ARE BEING SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE CORONAVIRUS AND
WE'VE ALSO ASKED THE VARIOUS
SERVICES OF MORTGAGE LOANS TO
EXERCISE AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
EXERCISE THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MADE THE LOAN, WHO ESTABLISHED
THE MORTGAGE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY.
WHAT DOES HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY
IS THAT WE COVER ALL 8.5 MILLION
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF THE
MORATORIUM ON FORECLOSURES AND
EVICTIONS.
WE WANT ALSO FOR THE PHA'S TO BE
PROTECTED.
HUD DOES NOT HAVE AUTHORITY TO
MANDATE THAT EVICTIONS CAN OCCUR
BUT WE ARE IN CONTACT WITH ALL
OF PHA'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
ARE PETITIONING CONGRESS FOR THE
POWER TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE THAT,
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
MOST OF THE PHA'S ARE RUN BY
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE, SO WE REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN MUCH OF A PROBLEM
THERE.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN MUCH OF A
PROBLEM.
NEEDING TO TRY TO FORCE PEOPLE
TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO
IT.
PEOPLE ARE STEPPING UP AND
SAYING, WHAT CAN WE DO TO BE
HELPFUL.
AS FAR AS HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS, SECTION 8 IS
CONCERNED, THE APRIL VOUCHERS
WILL BE SENT OUT NEXT WEEK.
MAY VOUCHERS ARE ALREADY BEING
WORKED ON AND WE ARE ALSO
STAYING IN CONTACT WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS, ADVOCATES FOR
LOW-INCOME HOUSING AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE DOING THINGS THAT
ARE MOST HELPFUL TO THEM, AND
ADDITIONALLY, WE'VE EXTENDED THE
DEADLINES FOR HEALTH CARE AND
MULTIFAMILY FINANCIAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, AND THAT'S FOR
OVER 20,000 MULTIFAMILY AND
HEALTHCARE BORROWERS UNTIL APRIL
THE 30TH, AND THAT PROVIDES THEM
WITH A LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUES THAT THEY
ARE DEALING WITH.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK FAA
COMMISSIONER BRYANT MONTGOMERY
AS WELL AS FHA MARK CALABRIA AND
KATHY CRENSHAW, DIRECTOR OF, FP,
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
BRIDGE THE GAP, RECOGNIZING IT'S
A LOT EASIER FOR US TO TAKE THE
MEASURES AND FOR CONGRESS TO
TAKE THE MEASURES THAT THEY'RE
TAKING SO THAT WE DON'T DESTROY
A VERY EXCELLENT SYSTEM AND HAVE
TO START ALL OVER AGAIN, SO FOR
THOSE WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
MONEY THAT'S BEING SPENT, IF YOU
DON'T SPEND THE MONEY AND DEAL
WITH THIS NOW, IT'S GOING TO
COST A WHOLE LOT MORE TO TRY TO
BUILD THIS UP AGAIN.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
PRESIDENT, THERE'S BEEN A SENSE
OF UNITY THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
FOR A LONG TIME IN THIS COUNTRY
AND LET'S HOPE AND PRAY THAT
UNITY LAST FAR BEYOND THIS
CRISIS.
>> BEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> ANY QUESTIONS, PLEASE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, A QUESTION, IF
YOU DON'T MIND, SIR, IF YOU LOST
YOUR JOB NOW OR YOU'RE WORRIED
THAT YOU WILL LOSE YOUR JOB,
RESTAURANT, SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO DO
IMMEDIATELY?
SECOND QUESTION, SIR, YOU HEARD
FROM THE VICE PRESIDENT THAT
HE'S GOING TO BE TESTED.
ARE YOU TAKING A --
>> I JUST TOOK ONE.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I FEEL GREAT.
>> YOU TOOK --
>> HOLD ON.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> OKAY.
SO TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO LOST
THEIR JOB ALREADY OR WORRIED
THAT THEY ABOUT TO LOSE IT
TOMORROW, WHAT DO YOU WANT THEM
TO DO RIGHT NOW?
>> WHAT THEY DO RIGHT NOW IS
KEEP RECEIVING PAYCHECK TO AND
COMPANIES IN STRONG POSITION.
WE WANT TO KEEP EVERYTHING
TOGETHER BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE
TREMENDOUS BOUNCE-BACK.
SOME PEOPLE AGREE WITH THAT
STRONGLY.
SOME OF OUR TOP ECONOMISTS, ONCE
WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON, THE MEDICAL
PROBLEM, SO WE WANT THEM TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS, STAY WHERE YOU ARE
AND WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IF THEY DON'T, WE HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT, WE HAVE CHECKS, WE
HAVE A LOT OF THINGS HAPPENING,
POSITIVE THINGS.
NOBODY HAS EVER DONE.
THIS IS WORKING WITH DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS AN DEMOCRATS AND
MYSELF WORKING TOGETHER, NOBODY
HAS EVER DONE A PACKAGE LIKE
THIS.
IT'S A GREAT PACKAGE BUT IDEALLY
WE WANT THEM TO KEEP THEIR JOBS,
KEEP THE PAY COMING AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, KELLY,
GO AHEAD.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, ON YOUR
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT POWER,
ONE OF THE FEATURES OF THAT IS
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTROL THE
OUTPUT WHETHER IT'S MASKS OR
VENTILATORS, GET IT TO THE MOST
AREAS OF NEED AND CONTROL THE
PRICING TO KEEP IT AT A MARKET
LEVEL SO IT'S NOT PRICE GOUGING.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE HEARING
FROM GOVERNORS, THEY CAN'T FIND
SUPPLIES AND PRICES HAVE GONE
UP.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT BUT NOT
YET COMPELLED ANY COMPANIES, WHY
NOT?
>> WE HAVE SO MANY COMPANIES
MAKING SO MANY PRODUCTS,
PRODUCTS PLUS VENTILATORS, WE
HAVE CAR COMPANIES WITHOUT
HAVING TO USE THE ACT.
WE HAVE SO MANY THINGS BEING
MADE RIGHT NOW BY SO MANY,
THEY'VE JUST STEPPED UP.
IN FACT, MIKE PENCE AND I WERE
DISCUSSING IT BEFORE, WE'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT
WHERE THEY HAVE VOLUNTEERING, WE
WANT TO MAKE MASKS, GENERAL
MOTORS, FORD.
THEY WILL GO IN OPEN MARKET.
WE WANT THEM IN OPEN MARKET FROM
STANDPOINT OF PRICING BECAUSE
OTHER SIDE IT'S GOING -- WE
COULD BE UNFAIRLY --
>> DIRECT THEM TO PLACES IN
GREATEST NEED.
>> WE ARE DIRECTING STATES AND
SOMETIMES COMPETING AGAINST
STATES WHICH I DON'T WANT AND WE
WILL DROP OUT OF THE BIDDING.
WE WANT THE STATES TO GO FIRST
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE DOING,
WE ARE HELPING STATES.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
SAME THING WITH THE TESTING.
WE ARE HELPING STATES.
WE ARE HELPING STATES GET TO
WHERE THEY WANT AND WE'VE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN EVERY
ASPECT OF IT.
WELL, IT'S HAPPENING FAST RIGHT
NOW AND THE GOVERNORS ARE OUT
THERE TRYING TO GET AND IF THEY
ARE COMPETING WITH THAT, WE DROP
OUT.
PLEASE.
>> YOU SAID SOMETHING WE ARE
GOING TO BE GOING OVER TO THE
HILL, ARE YOU GOING YOURSELF?
>> MY PEOPLE ARE AND I WILL BE
STAYING HERE.
I WILL BE IN THE OVAL OFFICE AND
OTHER PLACES IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> YOU'RE ASKING CONGRESS TO
ESSENTIALLY PASS A SERIES OF
LEGISLATION, $2 TRILLION, 10% OF
GDP.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO MEMBERS IN
BOTH PARTIES WHO SAY THIS IS TOO
EXPENSIVE, THIS IS JUST TOO MUCH
TO DEBATE AND GET DONE IN 48
HOURS OR SO AND ALSO HAVE YOU
SPOKEN DIRECTLY WITH SPEAKER
PELOSI AT ALL ABOUT ANY OF THIS?
>> SO I'VE SPOKEN WITH -- I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY WHO I SPEAK
WITH BUT I'VE SPOKEN DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY EVERYBODY MANY, MANY
TIMES.
WE ARE DOING VERY WELL.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO COME UP
WITH A PACKAGE THAT'S GOING TO
BE REALLY SOMETHING VERY
SPECIAL.
IT'S GOING TO HELP PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THERE HAS
BEEN A CASE WHERE YOU WANT
PEOPLE NOT TO WORK.
YOU WANT TO CREATE INCENTIVE TO
WORK.
WE ARE CREATING NOT AN INCENTIVE
NOT TO WORK BUT THE FACT IS WE
ARE ASKING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK
BECAUSE OF -- WE HAVE TO STAY
AWAY FROM EACH OTHER.
IF WE ARE GOING TO KILL THIS
HORRIBLE HIDDEN ENEMY, WE HAVE
TO STAY AWAY.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A THING LIKE
THIS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
THE NATIONS ARE DOING SIMILAR
THINGS.
SOME EFFECTIVELY, SOME NOT
EFFECTIVELY.
THEY ARE DOING SIMILAR THINGS.
WE ARE CREATING A PACKAGE THAT'S
GOING TO KEEP COMPANIES
TOGETHER, KEEP WORKERS PAID SO
THEY CAN LIVE AND SUSTAIN.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE TIMING IS.
THE BIGGEST THING WE CAN DO IS
GET RID OF THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
KNOW, THE MEDICAL PROBLEM.
WE WANT TO HAVE THIS WHOLE
INCREDIBLE SITUATION THAT IT CAN
START RIGHT AWAY.
NOT THAT ALL THE COMPANIES BREAK
UP ALL THE WORKERS ARE OUT OF
JOB, YOU CAN'T PUT THEM BACK
TOGETHER AND YEARS TO PUT THEM
BACK TOGETHER, BECAUSE WE HAD
THE GREATEST ECONOMY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD UNTIL WE
GOT HIT WITH THIS PROBLEM.
WE CAN BE BACK VERY, VERY
QUICKLY, AND IT'S OUR INTENTION
TO BE BACK VERY QUICKLY AND WE
ARE DOING A PACKAGE THE LIKES
THIS NOBODY HAS EVER DONE
BEFORE.
I'M OBVIOUSLY THE ONE THAT HAS
TO APPROVE THE DIFFERENT THINGS
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS AND LIKE
BUYBACKS IS AN EXAMPLE.
I DIDN'T LIKE IT THE FIRST TIME
AND THIS TIME YOU'RE SAYING,
YOU'RE NOT DOING IT.
I DON'T WANT MONEY TO BE USED
FOR THAT.
I WANT MONEY OR THE USED FOR
WORKERS AND OPENING BUSINESSES,
KEEPING BUSINESSES, NOT
BUYBACKS.
WELL, I AM STRONGLY RECOMMENDING
A BUYBACK EXCLUSION.
YOU CANNOT BUY BACK YOUR STOCK,
YOU CAN'T TAKE A BILLION DOLLARS
AND BUY BACK AND INCREASE VALUE.
PLEASE.
>> HHS WAS ORDERING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF THEM, WAS THE ORDER
JUST PLACED TODAY, HOW IS THAT
GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED AND WHEN
CAN DOCTORS AND NURSES EXPECT TO
RECEIVE MASKS?
>> HHS IS COMPLETING HALF A
BILLION DOLLAR ORDER OF THE 95
MASKS AND ALL OF THIS IS BEING
COORDINATED THROUGH FEMA, AND WE
ARE RESPONDING SPECIFICALLY TO
STATE REQUESTS WHERE THE NEEDS
ARRIVE.
AS DR. FAUCI SAID, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE CONTRACTED
CORONAVIRUS HAVE THE PROTECTION
TO KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES HEALTHY, BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE, THE SUPPLY OF
SO-CALLED N95 MASKS HAS BEEN
VASTLY INCREASED IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT INSISTED
THAT WE EXTEND LIABILITY
PROTECTION TO INDUSTRIAL MASKS.
WHAT ALL THE EXPERTS TOLD US
EARLY ON THAT INDUSTRIAL MASKS
THAT ARE USED ON CONSTRUCTION
SITES, THE PRESIDENT IS FAMILIAR
WITH FROM HIS PAST LIFE, ARE
PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS, BUT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE LIABILITY
PROTECTION BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
CREATED FOR HOSPITALS.
WE WORKED WITH LEADERS IN BOTH
PARTIES, WE ADDED THAT
PROTECTION THAT RUNS THROUGH
2024, THAT NOW THE INDUSTRIAL
N95 MASKS CAN BE PURCHASED BY
HOSPITALS, PURCHASED BY STATES,
PURCHASED BY HHS AND DISTRIBUTE
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM, SO WE ARE
MAKING THOSE AVAILABLE, THE
SUPPLY HAS BEEN VASTLY INCREASED
AND ANOTHER STEP FORWARD IN A
BIPARTISAN ESTABLISHMENT AND WE
ARE CONTINUING TO USE ALL THE
KIND OF CREATIVE MEANS OF
AMERICAN INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LEANING INTO THIS
EFFORT AND THAT -- AND THAT WE
DO WHATEVER IT TAKES TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS HAVE THE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
>> WE ARE ALSO HEARING FROM
DOCTORS AND NURSES ABOUT THE
SHORTAGE, WHEN EXACTLY CAN THEY
EXPECT TO RECEIVE THE MASKS,
THOUGH?
>> LET ME PETE GAYNER SPEAK TO
THAT, HHS IS FULLY INTEGRATED
INTO FEMA AND AS THE REQUEST
COME IN, BUT OBVIOUSLY AS I'M
SURE THE ADMINISTRATOR WILL SAY,
THEY ARE BEING PRIORITIZED TO
THOSE AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
NEED.
>> SO WITHIN THE NATIONAL CENTER
WE HAVE A SUPPLY CHAIN TASK
FORCE AND IN A BASIC SENSE WE
ARE TRYING TO IDENTIFY THE
UNIVERSE OF WHAT'S OUT THERE,
WHETHER WE HOLD AT FEDERAL LEVEL
AND HOLD IT PRIVATE SECTOR AND
MASH IT UP WITH DEMAND AND
ASKING PEOPLE TO BE CREATIVE.
WE ARE ASKING, THIS IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE ARE ASKING LOCALS AND STATES,
TRY TO TAKE BURDEN OFF OF US AND
THEN WE WILL PRIORITIZE THOSE
SCARCE RESOURCES BECAUSE EVERY
SINGLE GOVERNOR ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS LOOKING FOR THE EXACT
SAME THING.
THERE'S A BALANCE BUT WE ARE
EXAMINING THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
>> WHEN DO MASKS START COMING?
>> THEY ARE OUT THERE NOW.
WE WANT TO MATCH -- WE WANT TO
GET OUT OF THE MIDDLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SO WE ARE TRYING TO MATCH
SUPPLIES WITH DEMAND.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO.
RIGHT NOW IT'S HAPPENING TODAY.
THERE'S A RANGE OF REQUESTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND WE ARE
TRYING TO MATCH THOSE, AGAIN,
SUPPLY AND DEMAND EVERY DAY.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> A LOT HAVE COME IN.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THE THROWING
AWAY OF THE MASKS BEING IN
PRIVATE BUSINESS, THE THROWING
AWAY OF THE MASK RIGHT AWAY AND
WHEN YOU HEAR 55 MILLION MASKS,
55 MILLION, HOW COULD IT
POSSIBLY BE SUCH A NUMBER, THEY
SAY THAT'S JUST A SMALL FRACTION
OF WHAT WE NEED, AND I SAID, WHY
AREN'T WE SANITIZING MASKS.
I LOOKED AT ALL THE DIFFERENT
MASKS.
SOME DON'T LEND THEMSELVES TO
DOING THAT BUT MANY DO.
WE HAVE VERY GOOD LIQUIDS FOR
DOING THIS, SANIFIESING THE
MASKS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THEY'RE STARTING TO DO MORE AND
MORE, SANITIZING THE MASKS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THAT.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> CDC GUIDANCE IS ABOUT HOW YOU
CAN MINIMIZE THE USE OF MASKS BY
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT YOU COULD
DO WITH TESTING AND WHEN YOU
HAVE MASKS, HOW YOU MIGHT REUSE
THEM, WHICH ONES YOU CAN REUSE.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S A
SOLUTION TO THIS OTHER THAN
BUYING MORE MASKING, CHANGE HOW
THEY ARE USING THEM?
>> WELL, THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
THINGS, ONE, FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE
MOVING TOWARDS GETTING TESTING
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
PTE.
I WILL NOT TELL YOU THE DATE
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A SWAB THAT YOU
CAN STICK IN THE NOSE OF THE
PERSON WHO IS EITHER INFECTED OR
NOT BUT THAT PERSON DOES NOT
NEED PPE.
IF YOU CAN DO A SELF-ADMINISTER
TEST, STICK IT IN A VILE, YOU
DON'T NEED A MASK AND YOU DON'T
NEED PPE.
>> I WOULD HAVE LIKED THAT MUCH
BETTER PERSONALLY, GO AHEAD.
>> THIS IS ANOTHER STORY ABOUT
GREAT AMERICAN INDUSTRY.
THE PRESIDENT AND I LITERALLY
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM APPLE THAT
THEY ARE DONATING 2 MILLION
INDUSTRIAL MASKS TO THIS EFFORT
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND WORKING
WITH OUR ADMINISTRATION TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE, AND IT MIGHT
BE A GOOD IMPORTANT FOR US TO
RENEW OUR CALL FOR AS THE
PRESIDENT AND I DELIVERED THE
MESSAGE TO BUSINESSES YESTERDAY,
MANUFACTURERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO GO TO YOUR
STOREROOM AND IF YOU HAVE N95
MASKS.
IF YOU HAVE 100 OF THEM OR
10,000 OF THEM, IS TO LOAD THEM
UP, DRIVE THEM OVER TO YOUR
LOCAL HOSPITAL.
THAT STORY IS LITERALLY
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND NOW WITH MORE AMERICANS STEP
AGOWAY -- STEPPING AWAY FROM
ELECTIVE SURGERY AND DENTAL
CARE, LOOKING AT AMERICANS TO
LOOKING AT THEIR SUPPLIES FOR
N95 MASKS AND MAKING THEM
AVAILABLE TO THE HOSPITALS.
THE GREAT NEWS AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
DOING IT NOW.
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING TODAY.
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IN
BUSINESS, ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IN
DENTISTRY IN PARTICULAR, LOOK AT
THE SUPPLIES OF N95 MASKS, PACK
UP AS MANY AS YOU CAN SPARE,
DROP THEM OFF AT YOUR LOCAL
HOSPITAL.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT SERVICE TO
THE COUNTRY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I JUST WANT TO
READ YOU SOME OF WHAT THE
DOCTORS IN THE FRONT LINES ARE
SAYING.
>> THE ONES SAYING GOOD THINGS
OR BAD THINGS?
>> THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO WAY TO
PROTECT MYSELF.
SURGEON IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE AT
WAR WITH NO AMO, DR. MEL IN
ILLINOIS, THIS IS THE WORST
SITUATION THAN NOW IS THE TIME
TO ACT.
I KNOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INCREASING PRODUCTION AT SO MANY
FACILITIES TO GET THE MASKS OUT,
BUT GIVEN THAT THIS IS THE MOST
WEALTHIEST POWERFUL COUNTRIES IN
THE WORLD, SHOULD THIS EVEN BE
HAPPENING?
>> I TELL YOU THE WAY I LOOK AT
IT.
MANY ADMINISTRATIONS PROCEEDED
ME, FOR THE MOST PART THEY DID
VERY LITTLE IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
YOU CAN SPEAK TO TONY, YOU CAN
SPEAK TO ANYBODY.
THISTHIS IS UNPRECEDENTED OR JUT
ABOUT UNPRECEDENTED.
AS TIME GOES BY WE ARE SEEING A
LEVEL THAT NOBODY WOULD HAVE
BELIEVED OR THOUGHT POSSIBLE
THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN, AND WE
ARE MAKING MUCH OF THIS STUFF
NOW AND MUCH OF IT IS BEING
DELIVERED NOW.
WE'VE ALSO GOTTEN TREMENDOUS
REVIEWS FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEY CAN'T BELIEVE HOW FAST IT'S
COMING.
WHEN I HEAR THEY HAVE AN ORDER
OF 55 MILLION MASKS AND THAT'S
JUST ONE ORDER, THAT'S ONE ORDER
OUT OF MANY AND THAT THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF MASKS BEYOND THAT.
I KEEP SAYING, HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE TO USE SO MUCH AND
THAT'S THE WAY IT IS.
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE THEY'LL
USE A MASK FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AND THEY THROW IT.
THE FACT IS THAT WE ARE DOING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
WE STARTED VERY FEW MASKS, WE
HAD SOME BUT NOTHING FOR AN
EVENT LIKE THIS AND NOW WE ARE
TAKING TENS OF MILLIONS OF MASKS
AND OTHER THINGS.
I THINK IT'S UNPRECEDENTED WHAT
WE HAVE DONE AND WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
MANY DOCTORS AND I'VE READ MANY,
MANY DOCTORS, THEY CAN'T BELIEVE
THE GREAT JOB THAT WE ARE DOING.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> LEARN ABOUT THIS -- ABOUT
THIS VIRUS --
>> WELL, IF YOU REMEMBER I WAS
THE ONE THAT CLOSED THE COUNTRY
DOWN.
I WAS THE ONE TO CLOSE THE --
YOU DON'T WRITE THAT, CERTAINLY
ON CNN, BUT I JUST READ AN
ARTICLE YESTERDAY, I JUST READ
AN ARTICLE YESTERDAY THAT BY
CLOSING THE COUNTRY DOWN SO
EARLY, VERY EARLY WE SAVED TENS
OF THOUSANDS AND MUCH MORE THAN
THAT LIVES, SO, YOU KNOW, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO REPORT THAT TOO.
>> I JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT
FOR A MOMENT.
AGAIN, I'M AN ICU PHYSICIAN, RAN
HEALTH SYSTEMS AND FIRST OF ALL
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE ON THE
FRONT LINES IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOMS, ICU'S AND HOSPITALS.
I SPEAK TO MY COLLEAGUES DAILY.
WE NEED TO PRESERVE OUR PPE TO
THE DEGREE THAT WE CAN, CDC
GUIDELINES HAS HAD THAT, THE
PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT IT.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY WE ARE MAKING
PRODUCT AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
BUT WE ARE ALSO RESPONDING
THROUGH THE FEMA SYSTEM TO
DISTRIBUTE THE STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE ACCORDING TO
REQUESTS THAT COME IN.
STOCKPILE HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED
TO MANY STATES.
FIRST ORDER, SECOND ORDER AND ON
A DAILY BASIS ADJUDICATING THAT.
IF THERE ARE SHORTAGES IN YOUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM, I CAN'T TELL
YOU OF DOCTOR X, Y AND Z.
THAT NEEDS TO BE CLEARLY IT
RATED TO THE LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT.
>> HOSPITALS TALKING ABOUT --
>> 3 NIGHTS AGO WITH OVER 2,000
HOSPITALS OR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
SHARING BEST PRACTICES FROM
SEATTLE WHERE THEY'VE BEEN VERY
INNOVATIVE PIONEERING SOME SOMEF
THE AREAS.
WHEN THERE'S A SHORTAGE, THEY
NEED TO GO THROUGH EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT, GOES DIRECTLY UP TO
FEMA SYSTEM WHICH REALLY ROCKS,
IT REALLY WORKS VERY, VERY WELL
AND THEN THERE'S A DISTRIBUTION
OF THE STOCKPILE.
NOW THE STOCKPILE ISN'T
INFINITE, IT'S BEING REPLACED.
MASKS GO OUT ON A DAILY BASIS AS
THEY ARE NEEDED AND REQUESTED
THROUGH THE FEMA SYSTEM AND I
DON'T KNOW ADMINISTRATOR GAYNER,
WHETHER YOU WANT TO ADD TO THAT.
>> JUST TO REITERATE WHAT BRETT
SAID, WE DON'T TAKE LIKELY WHAT
YOU JUST READ.
I GET THE CALLS EVERY NIGHT THE
WAY YOU GET EMAILS.
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE.
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
IT IS HAPPENING.
YOU'RE NOT MAKING THINGS UP.
I KNOW THAT BECAUSE I'M
EXPERIENCING MYSELF.
BUT WHAT YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT AVENUES, SOME WHICH
AREN'T EVEN RECOGNIZED ABOUT HOW
YOU CAN GET HELP THROUGH THE
FEMA PROCESS IN ADDITION TO
LARGE AMOUNTS OF ADDITIONAL
PPE'S THAT'S COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM.
HOPE THAT VERY SOON WE WILL NOT
GET THOSE KINDS OF REAL-LIFE
DIFFICULTIES.
>> THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT THE
TIMELINE HERE AND EVEN FEMA
CAN'T QUITE ANSWER WHAT THE TIME
LINE IS.
>> SOONER THAN WEEKS, IT'S GOING
TO BE DAYS, I WOULD HOPE.
WE WILL TRY TO MAKE IT DAYS TO
THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY WE CAN.
>> AGAIN, WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
TRYING TO HELP THE STATES GET
THINGS FASTER AND THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE DOING.
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING AND THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS -- IT'S A
TRAGEDY, THE MAGNITUDE IS
SOMETHING THAT NO MATTER WHO YOU
ARE, WHERE YOU COME FROM, NOBODY
EVER THOUGHT A THING LIKE THIS
COULD HAPPEN.
YOU READ ABOUT 1917 AND YOU READ
ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS BUT YOU
THINK IN A MODERN AGE LIKE THAT
COULD NEVER HAPPEN.
WELL, IT COMES BACK.
IT IS GENIUS.
IT COMES BACK AND IT'S TOO BAD
AND THE PEOPLE WORKING ON THIS
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE.
THE JOB THAT THEY HAVE DONE IS
INCREDIBLE.
THERE'S TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
NOT ONLY MASK, VENTILATORS,
RESPIRATORS, EVERYTHING THAT YOU
CAN THINK OF, IT'S ALL BEING
MUCH OF IT AND ALMOST I COULD
SAY ALL OF IT IS BEING
MANUFACTURED RIGHT NOW.
STEVE, PLEASE.
>> YESTERDAY THERE WERE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE USE OF THE
MALARIA DRUG, HAVE THOSE
QUESTIONS NOW BEEN RESOLVED?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT RESOLVED.
I COULD SAY THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE DISTRIBUTED.
I KNOW NEW YORK IS GETTING I
THINK TEN THOUSAND UNITS AND
NUMEROUS OTHER PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY -- IT COULD BE THE
MALARIA DRUG PLUS THE Z PAC BUT
WE WILL FIND OUT, WE ARE GOING
TO FIND OUT.
LOOK, I FEEL AS THE IMPRESSION
GOES, WHAT DO WE HAVE TO LOSE,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I FEEL -- I
FEEL VERY GOOD ABOUT IT.
TONY WOULD FEEL LIKE HE LIKES
SAMPLES DONE AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT TOO.
MANY DOCTORS AGREE WITH THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME.
WE HAVE A LOT OF VERY SICK
PEOPLE IN HOSPITALS ALL OVER THE
PLACE AND SPEAKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK, CUOMO, I
SAID HOW DOES IT LOOK, HE HAS A
LOT OF SICK PEOPLE, SO WE ARE
GOING TO BE DELIVERING A LOT OF
SAMPLES TO NEW YORK AND OTHER
PLACES AND WE ARE GOING TO FIND
OUT VERY SHORTLY WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S GOING TO WORK.
I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT.
I MEAN, I'VE SEEN THINGS THAT
SURPRISE ME FRANKLY.
THERE ARE AS TONY SAID, THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS WE ARE LOOKING
AT TOO, VACCINE, OF COURSE, IS
INCREDIBLE, BUT THIS IS MORE
IMMEDIATE.
RIGHT NOW THIS TO ME WOULD BE
THE GREATEST THING THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
THIS WOULD BE A GIFT FROM
HEAVEN, THIS WOULD BE A GIFT
FROM GOD IF IT WORKS.
WE ARE GOING TO PRAY TO GOD THAT
IT DOES WORK, FANTASTIC THING.
YEAH, PLEASE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, ON THE
ECONOMIC FRONT THERE ARE REPORTS
THAT THE CORONAVIRUS IS REALLY
HURTING YOUR BUSINESSES,
ESPECIALLY YOUR HOTELS.
>> MY BUSINESSES?
SURE.
I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S THRIVING
WHEN YOU DECIDE TO CLOSE DOWN
YOUR HOTELS AND YOUR BUSINESSES,
NO, I WOULD SAY -- I'M VERY
UNDERLEVERED IN EVERYTHING SO
THAT'S GOOD.
IS IT HURTING ME, YEAH, IT'S
HURTING HILTON, IT'S HURTING ALL
THE GREAT HOTEL CHAINS ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
IT'S HURTING EVERYBODY.
VERY FEW BUSINESSES THAT ARE
DOING WELL.
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE LIKE AS
AN EXAMPLE THE WAL-MARTS OF THE
WORLD BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS LINED
TO GET THINGS AND STOCK UP THEIR
HOUSE AND THIS AND THAT, BUT,
SURE, IT HURTS MY BUSINESS, BUT
--
>> DOES YOU OR ANYBODY IN YOUR
ADMINISTRATION TALKED TO ANYONE
AT THE TRUMP
>> I DIDN'T SPEAK TO ANYBODY, I
SPOKE TO MY SONS.
THEY BASICALLY FOLLOW THE RULES,
WHEN THEY SAY CLOSE THEM DOWN IN
NEW YORK, WE CLOSE THEM DOWN OR
WHEREVER THEY MAY BE HAVING
THEM.
I HAVE THEM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
WHEN THEY SAY CLOSE THEM DOWN,
WE CLOSE THEM DOWN.
>> WILL YOU NO LONGER GO TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> I HAVE NOTHING PLANNED AT
RIGHT NOW I THINK MAR-A-LAGO I
GUESS -- I HAVEN'T ASKED, BUT I
IMAGINE THAT'S CLOSED DOWN LIKE
A LOT OF OTHER BUSINESSES IN
FLORIDA.
GO AHEAD.
>> DO YOU EXPECT YOUR FAMILY
COMPANIES TO SEEK GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE WOULD
BE FOR WHAT I HAVE.
I HAVE HOTELS.
EVERYBODY KNEW I HAD HOTELS WHEN
I GOT ELECTED.
THEY KNEW I WAS A SUCCESSFUL
PERSON WHEN I GOT ELECTED SO
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
I GUESS I GET PAID $450,000 A
YEAR.
I GIVE IT UP.
I PUT IT BACK INTO THE NATION.
I USUALLY -- I HAVE TO -- BY THE
WAY, YOU HAVE TO DESIGNATE WHERE
YOU WANT IT, I OFTENTIMES GIVE
IT TO OPIOID RESEARCH AND
THINGS.
AS FAR AS THE HOTELS AND
EVERYTHING, I HAVE TO DO WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING.
I WOULD PROBABLY DECIDE TO CLOSE
THINGS UP.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING.
YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE GETTING
TOGETHER AND HOTELS AND CLUBS
AND EVERYTHING, YOU GET
TOGETHER.
WE WANT TO BEAT THIS DEAL.
I HAVE MANY OF THEM, HOTELS,
CLUBS, THINGS LIKE THAT WHERE
PEOPLE GET TOGETHER.
I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE A GOOD
PRACTICE TO CLOSE THEM UP.
GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, AS YOU KNOW,
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT MASKS.
WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT HOW NOT
EVERYONE NEEDS TO TAKE A TEST.
WHAT ABOUT A TEMPERATURE TEST.
WE ALL CAME INTO THIS ROOM AND
GOT TESTED BEFORE WE ENTERED.
>> I DO IT.
I HAVE TEMPERATURE TESTS.
I DIDN'T ASK EVERYBODY HERE.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY
HAD TEMPERATURE TESTS.
OTHERWISE I'M GOING TO RUN OFF
THE STAGE.
>> SHOULD THEY BE ON A MASS
DISTRIBUTION BASIS TOO?
>> I THINK THEY ARE, PRETTY
MUCH.
THE EASIEST THING IS THE
TEMPERATURE.
I THINK THEY ARE.
I DON'T KNOW.
ARE YOU LEARNING A LOT FROM THE
TEMPERATURE TEST, TONY?
COULD YOU MAYBE DISCUSS THAT FOR
A SECOND.
>> THEY HAVE A PLACE.
THEY'RE NOT INFALLIBLE.
RIGHT NOW, EVERY TIME --
CERTAINLY, HERE -- EVERY TIME I
GO INTO A DIFFERENT ROOM I GET
MY TEMPERATURE TAKEN.
WE SEE THAT ON THE OUTSIDE SOME
PEOPLE ARE DOING THAT.
>> I TOOK HIS TEMPERATURE.
>> VERY LOW.
THERE IS A ROLE FOR IT UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT I DON'T SEE IS A MASSIVE
DISTRIBUTION OF THERMOMETERS
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE A MAJOR
IMPACT ON WHAT I SHOWED WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
>> MR. PRESIDENT --
>> AND I SAY -- I'VE SEEN THINGS
WHEN TONY MENTIONS THERMOMETERS,
THEY AIM SOMETHING AT YOUR YOU
FOREHEAD.
THEY SAY THIS FAR AWAY, BOOM,
AND THEY TELL YOU WHAT YOUR
TEMPERATURE IS.
I SAY I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
I'VE LEARNED A LOT.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> THANK YOU.
THIS MORNING THE WASHINGTON POST
RAN A STORY SUGGESTING THAT YOU
DELAY TAKING ACTION ON THE VIRUS
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
DR. FAUCI INDICATED YOUR ACTION
IMPOSING THE TRAVEL BAN HELPED
AMERICA IMMENSELY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE
WASHINGTON POST.
>> WELL, I LOVE WHOEVER YOU'RE
WITH.
I THINK THAT'S SUCH A NICE
QUESTION.
NO, I THINK THE WASHINGTON POST
COVERS US VERY INACCURATELY,
COVERS ME VERY INACCURATELY.
I SAW THE STORY.
I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE.
BUT IT'S THE WASHINGTON POST AND
I GUESS WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT.
IT'S A VERY INACCURATE -- QUIET,
QUIET.
IT'S A VERY INACCURATE STORY.
FROM MANY PEOPLE I GET A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR HAVING CLOSED OUR
COUNTRY VERY EARLY TO A VERY
HEAVILY INFECTED COUNTRY.
CHINA.
UNFORTUNATELY, CHINA.
I WISH CHINA WOULD HAVE TOLD US
MORE ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
CHINA LONG PRIOR TO US READING
ABOUT IT, EVEN THOUGH THE NEWS
ISN'T EXACTLY DISSEMINATED AS
YOU KNOW, CHINA KICKED THE
WASHINGTON POST OUT OF CHINA AND
IT KICKED THE NEW YORK TIMES OUT
OF CHINA AND I GUESS THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL.
THAT'S OKAY.
I MEAN, IT'S WHAT THEY DO AND I
THINK IT'S A TERRIBLE THING THEY
DID.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S TERRIBLE
WHEN PEOPLE WRITE INACCURATELY
ABOUT YOU AND THEY WRITE
INACCURATELY ABOUT ME EVERY
SINGLE DAY, EVERY SINGLE HOUR.
AND BY THE WAY, YOUR GROUP
REALLY -- I REALLY THINK -- I
JUST SAY FAIR, NOT GOOD OR BAD.
I THINK YOU WRITE VERY FAIRLY
AND DO FAIR REPORTS ABOUT THE
GREAT JOB THAT ALL OF US ARE
DOING.
THAT THIS GROUP BEHIND ME IS
IT'S SO INSULTING WHEN THEY
WRITE PHONY STORIES THAT THEY
KNOW ARE FAKE NEWS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT INSULTING ME,
THEY'RE INSULTING EVERYBODY --
THESE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE WORKED SO HARD, SO LOCK,
THAT ARE THINKING ABOUT OTHER
THAN THIS INVISIBLE ENEMY.
THEY HAVE DONE SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE JOB.
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE AND WE'RE
GOING TO WIN AND THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF CELEBRATION WHEN WE WIN.
AND WE'RE GOING TO WIN WITH AS
FEW LIVES LOST AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S THE GAME.
WIN WITH AS FEW LIVES LOST AS
POSSIBLE.
IT'S A TOUGHEN MY.
IT'S -- TOUGH   ENEMY, IT'S A
TOUGH KILLER, MORE VICIOUS THAN
EVER BEFORE.
I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING IT.
THE FACT WE CLOSED SO EARLY TO
CHINA -- AND MOST PEOPLE --
LOOK, I WAS CALLED GLEE KNOW XEY
SLEEP OWE JOE BIDEN.
Y JOE BIDEN.I WAS CALLED A RACII
DECIDED I DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE WHO
COULD HURT OUR COUNTRY COME IN.
MOST PEOPLE, EVEN THAT WORKED IN
THE WHITE HOUSE DISAGREED WITH
ME VERY STRONGLY.
SAVING OF THOSE MANY WEEKS WAS A
TREMENDOUS THING.
WHEN THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT
ACTING EARLY, THAT WAS THE
ULTIMATE ACT.
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST ACT.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T.
AND THEN I ALSO CLOSED EUROPE
EARLY, VERY EARLY.
AND I TOOK A LOT OF HEAT FOR
THAT TOO.
BUT THAT WAS A GOOD THING.
NOW THEY'RE DOING SIMILAR THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING.
I DIDN'T ACT LATE.
I ACTED EARLY.
I ACTED FAR BEFORE ANYBODY
THOUGHT I SHOULD BE.
I TOOK TREMENDOUS CRITICISM FROM
THE VARIOUS PAPERS, FROM MANY OF
THE PAPERS.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN MORE OF A
STATEMENT THAN A QUESTION BUT
WHATEVER IT MAY HAVE BEEN, I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
>> MR. PRESIDENT --
>> NUMBER OF THE STATES HAVE
KIND OF DONE DIFFERENT MEASURES.
WE'VE SEEN CALIFORNIA ORDER ONE
THING, NEW YORK SOMETHING
SIMILAR.
DO YOU WANT ALL THE STATES TO DO
ONE UNIFORM --
>> NO, THEY CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
IF CALIFORNIA CAN GET A MASK
SOONER THAN WE CAN GET IT FOR
THEM THROUGH ALL OF THE THINGS
WE'RE ABLE TO DO, WE'RE GOING TO
END UP WITH AN OVERSUPPLY AT
SOME POINT.
AT SOME POINT THIS IS GOING AWAY
AND WE'LL HAVE A BIG OVERSUPPLY
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, IN THIS CASE
THAT'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
BUT IF GAVIN CAN GO OUT AND
ORDER GOWNS FASTER OR MASKS,
GOOD MASKS FASTER, OR OTHER
THINGS FASTER, THAT'S GOOD.
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF -- I MEAN,
THE COORDINATION WITH THE SHIPS
THAT WE'RE SENDING IN AS YOU
KNOW, THE MEDICAL SHIPS THAT
WE'RE SENDING IN, AND EVEN
CRUISE LINERS, WE'RE GOING TO BE
SENDING IN PROBABLY CRUISE
LINERS INTO SOME AREAS, IN
PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA AND IN
PARTICULAR NEW YORK, BUT IF
SOMEBODY CAN DO SOMETHING
FASTER, IF THEY CAN ORDER THAT
MASK FASTER THAN US, I WANT THEM
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT.
>> PEOPLE CAN'T LEAVE THEIR
HOMES, CERTAIN BUSINESS --
>> COORDINATE WITH THEM.
>> YOU DON'T WANT THAT ALL TO
BE THE SAME.
>> WE HAVE SOME STATES WHERE
THEY HAVE TWO OR THREE PEOPLE
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN
QUARANTINE.
YOU CAN'T PUT ON THEM WHAT
YOU'RE PUTTING IN NEW YORK WHERE
YOU DO HAVE A TREMENDOUS
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE LARGE PORTIONS OF THE
COUNTRY, MIDDLE AMERICA, WHERE
THEY HAVE A FEW PEOPLE.
SO IT MAY BE A TIME -- I HOPE
THAT NEVER HAPPENS WHERE WE NEED
TO TAKE VERY DRASTIC ACTION BUT
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT THE SAME
BALLPARK.
GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
>> YOUR 15 DAYS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS, A L OF PEOPLE
ARE FOLLOWING THEM.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT.
DO YOU THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE DOING ENOUGH RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK THEY ARE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT.
I THINK THEY ARE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
VERY PROFOUND EFFECT.
I MEAN, WE'LL KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON DAY 14 AND 15.
>> WHAT'S THE PLAN?
>> WE HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE
RESULT IS.
WE WANT TO FLATTEN THAT OUT AND
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT THE
RESULT IS.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY, I'M
GOING TO NEGOTIATE A VERY LARGE
TRANSACTION AND I'VE BEEN
NEGOTIATING IT FOR TWO DAYS.
SO I'M GOING TO TAKE ONE OR TWO
MORE QUESTIONS AND THEN I'M
GOING TO LEAVE IT TO VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE ON THE HILL,
WITH THE HILL, THE VARIOUS
ELEMENTS OF THE PACKAGE.
STEVE, GO AHEAD.
>> A NUMBER OF GROUPS ARE
CALLING FOR THE POSTPONE PATIENT
OR CANCELLATION OF THE --
POSTPONEMENT OR CANCELLATION OF
THE OLYMPICS.
HAVE YOU --
>> YOU TAKE A LOOK AT SHINZO
ABE, HE'S A GREAT GENTLEMAN, HE
LOVES HIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
RELATIONSHIP.
WE JUST FINISHED A TRADE DEAL
WITH THEM, $40 BILLION TRADE
DEAL WITH JAPAN AND PRIME
MINISTER ABLE HAS -- ABE HAS A
BIG DECISION TO MAKE.
THEY'RE ALL READY TO GO.
IT'S NOT LATE.
IT'S NOT OVER-BUDGET.
IT WAS DONE FLAWLESSLY AND IT'S
BEAUTIFUL AND THEY'RE SITTING
BACK AND SAYING, YOU KNOW, -- I
TOLD HIM, I SAID THAT'S YOUR
DECISION.
AND IT IS HIS DECISION.
AND I KNOW HE'S GOING TO MAKE IT
SOON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
BE AND I DHIENGT I SHOULD BE
INFLUENCING IT AT ALL.
THE JOB THAT JAPAN HAS DONE ON
THAT VENUE IS INCREDIBLE.
SO I MEAN, THERE ARE OPTIONS,
OBVIOUSLY INCLUDING DELAY AND
MAYBE DELAY FOR NEXT YEAR BUT
THAT'S TOTALLY UP TO THEM.
WEE SEE WHAT THEY DO -- WE'LL
SEE WHAT THEY DO.
>> SINCE THE STORY KEEPS
POPPING UP, WHEN DID YOU FIRST
LEARN THAT THIS WAS GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WHEN I
LEARNED I STARTED DOING THE
CLOSINGS.
SO PROBABLY AROUND THAT TIME.
WE DIDN'T LEARN MUCH.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO ASK A
LITTLE ABOUT CHINA
RESPONSIBILITY.
I DO THINK THAT -- AGAIN, I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR CHINA.
I LIKE CHINA.
I THINK THE PEOPLE OF CHINA ARE
INCREDIBLE.
I HAVE A TREMENDOUS RELATIONSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT XI.
I WISH THEY COULD HAVE TOLD US
EARLIER ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON
INSIDE.
WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT UNTIL IT
STARTED COMING OUT PUBLICLY BUT
I WISH THEY COULD HAVE TOLD US
EARLIER BECAUSE WE WOULD HAVE
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION.
TONY FAUCI AND ALL OF THE
PEOPLE, THE TALENT THAT WE HAVE
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HAD
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS OF
ADDITIONAL TIME.
IF YOU KNEW THAT THIS WAS GOING
TO BE HAPPENING.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT TIME.
THEY READ ABOUT IT IN THE
NEWSPAPERS LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
CHINA WAS VERY SECRETIVE.
OKAY.
VERY, VERY SECRETIVE.
AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
WITH THAT, I HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR THAT COUNTRY.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
LEADER OF THAT COUNTRY.
AND LIKE HIM.
HE'S A FRIEND OF MINE.
BUT I WISH THEY WERE ABLE TO --
I WISH THEY WOULD HAVE TOLD US
EARLIER, STEVE, THAT THEY WERE
HAVING A PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY
WERE HAVING A BIG PROBLEM AND
THEY KNEW IT AND I WISH THEY
COULD HAVE GIVEN US AN ADVANCED
WARNING BECAUSE WE COULD HAVE
HAD A LOT OF THINGS AS AN
EXAMPLE, SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHERE WE
ORDER THEM AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
IF WE HAD A TWO OR THREE-MONTH
DIFFERENCE IN TIME, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH BETTER.
YEAH, PLEASE.
>> CAN I FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
BECAUSE AS YOU WERE SAYING,
CHINA WAS EXTREMELY SECRETIVE
ABOUT THIS, SEVERAL OF YOUR
ADVISORS HAVE BEEN WARNING --
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL OF CHINA,
SECRETARY POMPEO WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT YESTERDAY AND HE HAD
BEEN SAYING SO FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
SO WHY THEN ON JANUARY 24th
DID YOU TWEET THAT CHINA HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
CONTAIN THE CORONAVIRUS BUT THE
UNITED STATES GREATLY
APPRECIATES THEIR EFFORTS AND
TRANSPARENCY.
>> BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
>> IT WILL ALL WORK OUT WELL.
WHY WERE YOU SAYING THAT.
>> CHINA HAS WORKED VERY HARD.
CHINA HAS LOST THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS.
>> YOU SAID THEY WEREN'T
TRANSPARENT.
>> THEY WERE TRANSPARENT AT
THAT TIME.
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN TRANSPARENT
MUCH EARLIER THAN THEY WERE.
SO YOU UNDERSTAND, CHINA IS NOT
A BENEFICIARY HERE.
CHINA LOST THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
CHINA HAS GONE THROUGH HELL OVER
THIS.
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH HELL.
AND I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
PRESIDENT XI.
I JUST WISH THEY COULD HAVE TOLD
US EARLIER.
THEY KNEW THEY HAD A PROBLEM
EARLIER.
I WISH THEY COULD HAVE SAID
THAT.
>> ARE YOU ABLE TO SHARE --
THANK YOU FOR THE NUMBERS ON THE
TESTING.
ARE YOU ABLE TO SHARE ANY OTHER
HARD NUMBERS ON NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE TESTS, NUMBER OF
VENTILATORS IN THE FEDERAL
STOCKPILE.
>> I'M GOING TO LEAVE THAT UP
TO DR. FAUCI AND EVERYBODY ELSE
AND I THINK THE ANSWER IS WE
WANT TO SHARE THE NUMBERS AS --
ADD INITIAL, DO YOU WANT TO --
ADMIRAL, DO YOU WANT TO SHARE.
>> 500 MILLION MASKS, HALF A
MILLION MASKS, -- HALF A BILLION
MASKS -- THE NUMBER OF
VENTILATORS WE HAD WAS 12 TO
13,000.
>> A VENTILATOR IS A MACHINE.
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX MACHINE.
AND TO THINK WE HAVE TO ORDER
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
NOBODY'S EVER HEARD OF A THING
LIKE THIS.
WHEN WE HAD IN THE STOCKPILE, WE
HAD THOUSANDS IN A STOCKPILE,
THOUSANDS READY TO GO.
THAT'S A LOT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU NEED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
AND YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT --
THE MASK IS WHETHER IT'S PLASTIC
OR WHETHER IT'S MATERIAL, THAT'S
ONE THING.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
SOPHISTICATED, HEAVILY
COMPUTERIZED MACHINE AND DEL DEL
DELICATE AND YOU NEED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF THEM.
NOBODY HEARD OF A THING LIKE
THAT GENERAL MOTORS, FORD, SO
MANY COMPANIES -- I HAD THREE
CALLS YESTERDAY DIRECTLY,
WITHOUT HAVING TO INSTITUTE LIKE
YOU WILL DO THIS, THESE
COMPANIES ARE MAKING THEM RIGHT
NOW.
BUT TO THINK OF THESE NUMBERS,
IT'S PRETTY MIND BOGGLING.
>> DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS TO SHARE
WITH US RIGHT NOW, THE
STOCKPILE.
>> PLEASE.
>> WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT MASKS
THIS MORNING.
THE PRESIDENT'S ALSO GIVEN THE
TASK FORCE A PRIORITY OF
ASSESSING THE AVAILABILITY AND
EXPANDING THE AVAILABILITY OF
VENTILATORS AND ON MONDAY WE
WILL DETAIL SOME VERY
ENCOURAGING NEWS FOR AMERICANS.
YOU SPEAK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
13,000.
IT IS A LITTLE MORE THAN THAT
THAT WE HAVE IN THE NATIONAL
STOCKPILE.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
MORE THAN 100,000 VENTILATORS
THAT ARE IN HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND HOSPITALS AROUND
AMERICA TODAY.
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE WHAT WILL BE
PRODUCED AS THE PRESIDENT SAID,
WE'RE SEEING COMPANIES STEP
FORWARD.
MANUFACTURERS TELL US THAT A
VENTILATOR ACTUALLY ISN'T A VERY
COMPLICATED PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
AND MANY OF THEM ARE LITERALLY
SURGING FORWARD TO CREATE MORE
VENTILATORS.
ONE OF THE MORE EXCITING
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE LAST WEEK
WHICH WE'LL DETAIL MORE ON
MONDAY IS THAT IN THE
PRESIDENT'S ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE COMMUNITY, WE
LEARNED THAT VENTILATORS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY USED BY
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS, THAT ARE USED
IN OUTPATIENT CLINICS AND OTHER
PROCEDURES CAN BE CONVERTED TO
BE USED AS VENTILATORS FOR
PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH THE
EFFECTS OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE'VE CONFIRMED THAT A
PARTICULAR SCREEN IN THAT DEVICE
CAN BE CHANGED READILY.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE FDA TO
APPROVE THAT.
BUT AGAIN, THIS IS A -- IT'S A
GREAT TESTAMENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND OUR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE STEPPING
FORWARD AND BRINGING IDEAS
FORWARD THAT LITERALLY AS WE'LL
DOCUMENT MONDAY WILL INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF VENTILATORS BY
TENS OF THOUSANDS.
BUT, LOOK, THE PRESIDENT'S MADE
IT CLEAR, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE INCREDIBLE
COURAGEOUS MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
SERVING IN HEALTH CARE AROUND
AMERICA HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED, THAT OUR PATIENTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH RECOVERING FROM
CORONAVIRUS HAVE THE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED AND WE'LL HAVE A LOT
OF DETAIL ON MONDAY AS WE
CONTINUE TO ASSESS.
>> 1.4 MILLION TESTS ON-BOARD
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK, BY
TODAY.
DO WE HAVE THAT?
CAN YOU GIVE US THE NUMBER WE
HAVE?
>> LET ME LET THE ADMIRAL SPEAK
TO THAT.
>> I'M GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND TRY TO PERSUADE YOU
TO STOP ASKING ABOUT A SPECIFIC
NUMBER.
OKAY?
SO FROM MARCH 2nd TO
MARCH 14th, WE HAVE PUT OVER
10 MILLION LABORATORY TESTS INTO
THE U.S. COMMERCIAL MARKET AND
WE EXPECT THAT BY MARCH 28th
TO BE WELL OVER 27 MILLION INTO
THE MARKET.
SO THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT QUESTION.
NOT EVERY LAB CAN RUN EVERY
TEST.
NOT EVERY TEST IS COMPLETELY
SELF-CONTAINED.
SO THE MORE IMPORTANT QUESTION
IS NOT HOW MANY TESTS ARE IN THE
MARKET.
WE GOT THEM IN THE MARKET.
BUT IT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
SEGMENT OF THE MARKET HAS THE
KIND OF TEST THAT THEY CAN USE.
>> WE'RE USING YOUR NUMBERS,
TRYING TO FIND OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC IF THE THINGS YOU'VE
PROMISED ARE HAPPENING.
>> YES, THEY ARE HAPPENING.
THEY ARE.
WE PROMISED ONE OR 4 MILLION.
THERE'S 10 MILLION TESTS IN THE
MARKET NOW.
>> ARE THE MASKS THAT ARE IN
THE STRATEGIC RESERVE BEING
DEPLOYED, MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
>> YES, THE MASKS IN THE
STRATEGIC NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
>> IT'S NOT 13,000 ANYMORE, IT
WOULD BE A LOWER NUMBER, IS THAT
FAIR TO SAY.
>> MASKS?
>> VENTILATORS.
I'M SORRY, THE RESPIRATORS.
>> RESPIRATORS.
>> THANK YOU.
WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF
THE THINGS WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THROUGH THESE BRIEFINGS FOR MANY
DAYS ARE HAPPENING AND GETTING
INTO THE HANDS OF THE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS.
>> YOU UNDERSTAND IT.
YOU UNDERSTAND IT.
YOU UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT HE'S
SAYING.
WHAT HE'S SAYING IS RATHER
INCREDIBLE.
WE INHERITED AN OBSOLETE, BROKEN
SYSTEM.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE NUMBER OF
TESTS THAT WE'LL BE PROVIDING
AND ARE NOW, IT'S INCREDIBLE.
AND I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
GOVERNORS SAY THE SAME THING.
WE TOOK OVER AND OBSOLETE,
BROKEN TESTING SYSTEM THAT
WOULDN'T HAVE WORKED FOR EVEN A
SMALL PROBLEM, LET ALONE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PANDEMICS IN HISTORY
AND WHAT THESE GENTLEMEN HAVE
DONE IS INCREDIBLE.
I AM GOING NOW TO NEGOTIATE A
GREAT DEAL FOR OUR WORKERS AND
OUR CITIZENS.
I'LL BE BACK TOMORROW.
WE'LL PROBABLY BE DOING THIS
TOMORROW.
I'D LIKE TO ASK VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE TO TAKE OVER AND THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT --
>> THANK YOU ALL.
>> BACK HERE.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THE
MILITARY HAS COMPLAINED TO --
[]-- TO PICK UP AMERICANS AND
BRING THEM HOME.
THERE ARE A LOT OF AMERICANS WHO
ARE STRANDED AND CAN'T GET HOME.
DOES THE MILITARY PLAN TO SEND
PLANES TO PICK THEM UP.
CAN YOU ENSURE AMERICANS THAT
ARE STRANDED THAT THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO GET HOME.
>> WE RECEIVED A BRIEFING THIS
MORNING FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THEIR EFFORTS
AND WE WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT HAS
SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL FROM EUROPE
INCLUDING THE U.K. AND IRELAND,
SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL FROM CHINA
SINCE JANUARY, ANY AMERICAN WHO
CAN GET HOME CAN COME HOME.
THEY'LL GO THROUGH ADDITIONAL
SCREENING, THAT'S ALL BEEN
IMPLEMENTED.
AND IS WORKING IN AN ORDERLY
WAY AT A NUMBER OF AIRPORTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
BUT THERE ARE INSTANCES, MOROCCO
BEING AMONG THEM, WHERE THERE
SIMPLY ARE NOT FLIGHTS TO GET
HOME.
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
EMBASSIES IN THOSE RELEVANT
COUNTRIES.
I WAS TOLD THIS MORNING THAT ALL
THE WAY GOING BACK TO BRINGING
AMERICANS BACK FROM CHINA THAT
WE HAVE MADE INDIVIDUAL EFFORTS
TO BRING HOME ABOUT 3,000
AMERICANS.
I THINK THERE IS AN ONGOING
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THAT WITH
CHARTERED COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
PROVIDING, OBVIOUSLY ALSO
MILITARY TRANSPORT IS AVAILABLE
BUT OUR TASK FORCE RECEIVED A
BRIEFING THIS MORNING AND WE
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE ANY
AMERICAN THAT'S LOOKING ON FROM
OVERSEAS, CONTACT THE LOCAL U.S.
EMBASSY.
LET THEM KNOW ABOUT YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO WORK -- CONTINUE
TO WORK VERY DILIGENTLY TO GET
OUR AMERICANS HOME.
>> LAST QUESTION.
>> TWO QUICK ONES.
EDUCATION AND MEDICATION ONE.
YOU GUYS HAVE ANNOUNCED THAT
STANDARDIZED TESTING IS
ESSENTIALLY CANCELED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
TO THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS OUT THERE, THE TEACHERS
AND THEIR PARENTS WHO ARE SORT
OF SCRATCHING THEIR HEAD,
WONDERING WHAT DOES THAT MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF THIS IS
DRIVEN BY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, BY THE STATE.
IS THERE ANY FEDERAL GUIDANCE ON
THIS?
AND IF NOT TODAY, COULD YOU HAVE
SECRETARY DEVOS OR SOMEBODY COME
AND EXPLAIN THAT TO THE MILLIONS
THAT ARE SITTING AT HOME, TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> I THINK IT'S A TERRIFIC
QUESTION.
AND WE WILL BRING SECRETARY
BETSY DEVOS HERE TOMORROW OR ON
MONDAY TO ADDRESS OUR EFFORTS.
THE OBJECTIVE HERE WAS AS PEOPLE
ARE EMBRACING THE PRESIDENT'S 15
DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD, WE HAVE
DECISIONS BY LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
AND LOCAL AND STATE OFFICIALS
THAT HAVE CANCELED SCHOOL OR
SUSPENDED SCHOOL FOR A TIME AND
WE WANTED THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THE BURDEN OF STANDARDIZING
TESTING, WHICH BACK IN MY DAY AS
GOVERNOR I REMEMBER TAKES A
NUMBER OF DAYS AND SOMETIMES UP
TO A WEEK TO ADMINISTER, IS NOT
GOING TO BE PLACED ON SCHOOLS
BUT WE'LL HAVE THE SECRETARY
HERE TO ADDRESS THAT VERY
SPECIFICALLY AND IT'S A VERY
GOOD POINT ON YOUR PART.
>> I MENTIONED I HAVE A
MEDICATION QUESTION AND I WANTED
TO ASK IT WHILE THE PRESIDENT
WAS HERE.
BECAUSE EARLIER HE TWEETED THAT
THERE WERE TWO MEDICATIONS THAT
WHEN TAKEN TOGETHER, QUOTE, HAVE
A REAL CHANCE TO BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST GAME CHANGERS IN THE
HISTORY OF MEDICINE AND THEY
SHOULD BE, QUOTE, PUT IN USE
IMMEDIATELY.
SINCE HE'S NOT HERE, I CAN'T ASK
HIM WHAT HE MEANT BUT I'M
WONDERING IF DR. FAUCI OR THE
ADMIRAL COULD CLARIFY IF YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT AND WHETHER HIS
74.5 MILLION TWITTER FOLLOWERS
SHOULD BE TAKING MEDICAL ADVICE
FROM HIM OR FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT
TOGETHER THE TOP PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES IN AMERICA AND IN THE
WORLD A NUMBER OF WEEKS AGO.
AND THEY FORMED A CONSORTIUM TO
WORK ON A RANGE OF RESPONSES,
BEGINNING WITH THERAPEUTICS,
WHICH FOR A LAYMAN LIKE ME THAT
JUST MEANS MEDICINE TO MAKE YOU
FEEL BETTER.
THEY'RE ALREADY GOING TO WORK ON
THAT.
WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT
DR. FAUCI, I THINK THERE'S SOME
SENSE THAT OUR GREAT
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES MAY
ACTUALLY BE PRODUCING
THERAPEUTICS THAT WILL GIVE
RELIEF TO AMERICANS STRUGGLING
WITH CORONAVIRUS AS SOON AS THIS
SPRING.
WE ALSO CHALLENGED THEM TO WORK
TOGETHER AS RAPIDLY AS POSSIBLE
TO DEVELOP A VACCINE GOING
FORWARD AND AS DR. FAUCI HAS
INDICATED, WE BROUGHT A VACCINE
TO CLINICAL TRIALS, NOW THE
BETTER PART OF A WEEK AGO, THE
FASTEST TIME IN HISTORY.
NOW, IT'S THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
TRIALS AND PEOPLE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND AS OUR HEALTH EXPERTS
HAVE DESCRIBED THAT THERE WILL
BE A PERIOD OF AS MUCH AS A YEAR
AND-A-HALF BEFORE WE CAN MAKE
THOSE VACCINES AVAILABLE.
BUT AS THE PRESIDENT SAID AT
THIS PODIUM, THERE IS SOME
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE THAT SEVERAL
EXISTING MEDICINES MAY HAVE
BROUGHT RELIEF TO PATIENTS
STRUGGLING IN CHINA AND IN
EUROPE AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
TASKED THE FDA TO WORK VERY
RAPIDLY TO ALLOW WHAT'S CALLED
OFF-LABEL USE FOR THOSE.
ONE IS A MALARIA MEDICINE, BUT
THIS MORNING I THINK THE
PRESIDENT REITERATED THAT THE
HOPEFULNESS THAT HE FEELS ABOUT
THIS, THAT BECAUSE THESE ARE
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE TIME
HONORED AND TESTED, THEY'VE BEEN
TAKEN FOR MANY, MANY YEARS, THAT
WE WANT TO PURSUE, NUMBER ONE,
MAKING THOSE AVAILABLE IF
SOMEONE'S DOCTOR BELIEVES THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE, THE DOCTOR
WOULD BE ABLE TO PRESCRIBE THAT
MEDICINE EVEN THOUGH THAT'S NOT
INDICATED.
THAT'S CALL AN OFF-LABEL USE.
BUT THE OTHER PIECE IS, AS
DR. FAUCI SAID, AND I'LL YIELD
TO HIM, IN DEPLOYING THOSE
MEDICINES, WE'RE WORKING
SPECIFICALLY WITH ONE STATE TO
DO SO IN A WAY THAT REPRESENTS A
CLINICAL TRIAL.
SO IT WOULD NOT JUST BE COME COT
COMPASSIONATE USE WHICH IS USED
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS TODAY, BUT
ALSO WE COULD STUDY THE
VIABILITY OF IT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN TO MAKE SURE THOSE
MEDICINES ARE AVAILABLE.
DR. FAUCI, DO YOU WANT TO SPEAK
TO THAT?
>> SURE.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT I SAID
MULTIPLE TIMES ON THIS PODIUM IS
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE -- FIRST OF
ALL, WE'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP DE
NOVO DRUGS THAT ARE NOT YET OUT
THERE, NOT APPROVED, THAT
ULTIMATELY WOULD BE EFFECTIVE
AND THE WAY YOU PROVE THAT IS TO
DO A RANDOMIZED CONTROLLED TRIAL
TO PROVE SAFETY AND EFFICACY.
I'M NOT TOTALLY SURE OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS REFERRING TO BUT I
BELIEVE HE'S REFERRING TO A
REPORT THAT USED ABOUT HIGH
DOCKSY CHLOROQUINE AND --
HYDROXY CHLOROQUINE AND
ZYTHROMYACIN.
THE ONLY THING I WAS SAYING IS
THAT IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO
DEFINITIVELY KNOW IF SOMETHING
WORKS THAT YOU'VE GOT TO DO THE
KIND OF TRIAL THAT YOU GET THE
GOOD INFORMATION.
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
HOPE FOR PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT AN
UNREASONABLE THING TO HOPE FOR
PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU HAVE APPROVED DRUGS
THAT PHYSICIANS HAVE THE OPTION
AND A DECISION BETWEEN THE
PHYSICIAN AND THE PATIENT, ARE
YOU GOING TO USE A DRUG THAT
SOMEONE SAYS FROM AN ANECDOTAL
STANDPOINT, NOT COMPLETELY
PROVEN.
, BUT MIGHT HAVE SOMEEFFECT, THN
TO THE POINT OF GIVING HOPE AND
SAY GIVE THAT PERSON THE OPTION
OF HAVING ACCESS TO THAT DRUG
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE OTHER
GROUP, WHICH IS MY JOB AS A
SCIENTIST, TO SAY MY JOB IS TO
ULTIMATELY PROVE WITHOUT A DOUBT
THAT A DRUG IS NOT ONLY SAFE,
BUT THAT IT ACTUALLY WORKS.
THOSE TWO THINGS ARE REALLY NOT
INCOMPATIBLE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU'RE IN AN ARENA WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING THAT'S
PROVEN.
WE WENT THROUGH THE SAME SORT OF
THING WITH A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT TWIST DURING THE HIV
AIDS EPIDEMIC UNTIL WE FINALLY
DEVELOPED DRUGS THAT WERE
ABSOLUTELY KNOCK-OUT DRUGS THAT
WERE SAFE AND THAT WERE
EFFECTIVE.
BUT IN THE BEGINNING, THERE WAS
THAT TENSION ABOUT THAT SO
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A BALANCE.
I'VE GOT TO DO MY JOB AS A
SCIENTISTS AND OTHERS HAVE OTHER
THINGS TO DO.
>> GREAT.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT --
>> LET ME JUST, IF I MAY, LET ME
JUST SAY, I HOPE THIS MORNING
HAS BEEN INFORMATIVE.
WE WILL BE BACK AGAIN TOMORROW.
AND I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE ENCOURAGED BECAUSE OF THE
INCREDIBLE WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH, BECAUSE OF OUR
COLLABORATION WITH STATES.
YOU'RE SEEING TESTING EXPANDED
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT INCREDIBLE PUBLIC/PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMERCIAL LABS
IS NOW MAKING TESTING AVAILABLE
BY THE TENS OF THOUSANDS, WE'RE
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH AN
INCREDIBLE RESPONSE FROM
AMERICAN INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND VENTILATORS AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT OUR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS NEED TO MEET THIS
MOMENT IS THERE.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY AGAIN, WHAT
EVERY AMERICAN CAN DO TODAY.
AND THAT IS FIRST AND FOREMOST,
HEED YOUR STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
INDIVIDUAL STATES, CALIFORNIA,
WASHINGTON STATE AND AT THIS
MOMENT ESPECIALLY NEW YORK, THAT
HAVE ISSUED GUIDANCE TO THEIR
CITIZENS AND AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID, WE WHOLLY SUPPORT THE
LEADERSHIP THOSE GOVERNORS ARE
PROVIDING IN THEIR STATES.
SECONDLY, EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
CAN PUT INTO PRACTICE THE
PRINCIPLES OF OUR 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD.
THE PRESIDENT'S CORONAVIRUS
GLAXOSMITHKLINE AS I SAID, --
GUIDELINE AS I SAID WE'RE SIX
DAYS IN, AND THE PURPOSE OF
THESIS NOT BECAUSE EVERY
AMERICAN IS AT RISK OF SERIOUS
ILLNESS.
AS WE SAID BEFORE, ALL OUR
EXPERTS TELL US, ALL THE DATA
SHOWS, THAT THE RISK OF SERIOUS
ILLNESS TO THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
REMAINS LOW BUT BECAUSE THE
CORONAVIRUS IS WE THINK THREE
TIMES MORE CONTAGIOUS THAN THE
FLU, TO SLOW THE SPREAD, TO
LITERALLY LOWER THAT CURVE AND
SPARE AMERICANS AROUND OUR
COUNTRY WITH BEING EXPOSED TO OR
CONTRACTING THE CORONAVIRUS OR
WORSE, EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
CAN PUT THESE PRINCIPLES INTO
PRACTICE.
I RECOMMEND THAT YOU GO TO
CORONAVIRUS.GOV, SIT YOUR FAMILY
DOWN, CALL A NEIGHBOR AND A
FRIEND, SUPPORT EFFORTS IN YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY TO PUT THESE
(PELLS INTO PRACTICE --
PRINCIPLES INTO PRACTICE AND AS
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
CONTINUE TO DO JUST THAT, I JUST
KNOW WE'LL GET THROUGH THIS.
AND WE'LL GET THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU ALL.
LELAND:  THE PRESIDENT, THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM WRAPPING
UP AN HOUR AND-A-HALF LONG
CONFERENCE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT SAYING THIS
IS A WHOLE OF A